Hey everybody,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience has,
but to fucking set it again,
man said my own name again.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is an all in one platform that is simple and easy to use and allows
you to create an awesome website on your own with no help.
It is that easy.
It's as simple as attaching a photograph or a video to an email and sending it
to someone.
If you can do that,
you can make a website.
It's just simple drag and drop interface,
beautiful designs,
24 seven support through live chat and email they have the most.
It's as easy to make a website that engages all platforms as you could ever
possibly imagine.
So easy that they allow you to make your own website before you even enter in
your credit card information because they know you're going to go,
oh shit,
this is really good.
Squarespace also has a,
an a logo creator.
We can create a simple,
clean logo design for yourself in minutes.
You could set up an online store for yourself very easily and very quickly.
You can sell digital downloads like music.
If you're,
if you're a musician,
you could set it up super easy where you can sell music from your website.
We had a contest,
um,
this past year where we,
uh,
we picked four winners for Squarespace for the,
the best websites of the year.
And it was impossible to pick though those four people.
They had awesome websites,
but the people that we didn't pick,
they had awesome websites too.
It really is that easy to create a fantastic professional looking website.
And it used to be almost impossible to do.
It was just uh,
uh,
you know,
five,
six years ago they used to have to learn programs.
It was a huge pain in the ass.
Almost everyone who had a great website hired someone to do it.
It was just too difficult to do it on your own.
But now it's super easy and it is not expensive.
Plans start at $8 a month,
which includes a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year,
responsive designs that will work on all platforms.
I pads,
androids,
you can,
if you're a freak,
he could watch it on Unix.
You can look at it on Mac,
you can look at it on windows.
You're going to have the same website across the board.
Um,
for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com and enter in the code word Joe,
that's squarespace.com and enter in the code word Joe for 10% off.
Enjoy it.
And we're also brought to you by audible.com audible.com is the number one
source on the Internet for digital downloads,
for,
for books,
for lectures,
for you can get podcast comedy shows.
It's a fantastic resource if you're stuck.
[inaudible] excuse me.
If you're stuck on a plane,
you know,
on a regular basis or if you'd commute every day and that,
that time can be very frustrating for people,
but you can get lost in your own world with an excellent audible book.
And the,
the,
the audible resource,
the um,
the database they have is enormous.
Over 150,000 books and I really can't recommend them enough.
I've been using them for years.
In fact,
audible at one point in time was hiring comedians to come up with five new
minutes of material every week and they had like this whole download service
they were coming up with.
They stopped doing that because quite honestly,
it's very difficult to come up with five minutes.
It's worth downloading every week.
Um,
but if you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you can get a free audio book and a month,
a free month of audible service.
Once you use it,
you will get hooked because it is fantastic.
If I could recommend a book to you,
I would recommend Steven Pressfield's the art,
excuse me,
the war of art.
Not to be confused with the art of war.
Um,
it's a really excellent book for creative types,
for anybody who struggles with,
if you're a procrastinator,
if you're one of those people that just for whatever reason you feel like you
can't get shit done,
that you need to get shunned,
shit,
get shit done.
He really details in,
outlines it in a very clear way and he refers to it all as resistance.
It's one of the most powerful books I've ever read.
And it's a book that I,
I keep a stack of them at home and I hand out to friends,
uh,
just in case because a very small book,
it's a very easy read.
And I handed out to friends,
whatever anybody's like,
if anybody even remotely says,
ah,
I gotta do this thing,
I just go,
listen,
just read this book.
It'll help you do that thing,
whatever it is that you haven't been doing that you need to do.
So go to audible.com forward slash Joe and get a free audio book.
That is my recommendation.
And you will get one free audio book.
And again,
30 free days of audible service can't,
can't speak highly enough of a,
of audible.
They're fantastic.
We're also,
what's that?
Yeah.
I was just going to say,
we might also be soon doing as with audible and Squarespace,
both of those guys.
And,
and if we are,
then I also won't be able to speak highly enough of them.
Yeah,
they're great.
So just give me a couple of weeks and then I'll be doing it.
No,
seriously,
we already use Squarespace for one of our websites for it.
tyt.com yeah,
I have a bunch of friends he used Squarespace.
My friend Duncan Trussell uses it.
Kara Santa Maria uses it.
It's a,
I've never heard a single complaint.
Squarespace really does.
It's just as advertised.
Um,
last sponsor is on at.com.
O n n,
I t,
which is a human optimization website.
Basically what we sell is all kinds of shit to improve your physical fitness,
your,
your mind,
your immune system.
Anything that we find that is good that works for you,
for your body to help improve your conditioning.
We sell kettle bells and battle ropes and steel maces.
They look like weapons.
They're not weapons folks.
These are all um,
what we call functional strength,
uh,
equipment.
And what functional strength means is that you're using your entire body to,
uh,
to exercise with instead of a individual isolated movements like curls or things
along those lines.
And in doing so,
you actually improve athleticism and you improve the,
the ability to do work.
And you know,
there's,
it definitely makes your body look better.
But what's really important is if you're into any sort of sport will actually
improve your body's ability to do that sport.
Whether it's a,
you know,
you're into you,
you play a game or you're into martial arts for a martial artists,
the kettle bells,
one of the most popular pieces of strength and conditioning equipment,
it was a originally invented in Russia.
And,
uh,
I,
I don't know how they figured it out,
but it's a genius design.
It's essentially a giant cannon ball that's attached to a metal handle and you
swing it around and there's a series of movements that you can do with them and
just fantastic for strength and conditioning and just for blowing out stress.
I really can't recommend them enough.
Also at [inaudible] dot com we have,
uh,
an entire section called the Onnit academy.
And the audit academy is dedicated to instructionals for how to use strength and
conditioning equipment,
but also motivational videos that were done by guys like Tim Kennedy who's a
fighter in the UFC and uh,
who is a very fancy,
fascinating and interesting guy.
And we had him on the podcast last week and Tim's got a great video at
[inaudible] dot com as well as many,
many,
many others.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t used a codeword Rogan and save 10% of any
and all supplements.
That's o n n I t and use the code word Rogan Jake Ugur.
I said a right Jank Ugur to 100% not going to fuck it up like Larry King did.
Chank Ugur and he's here from the young Turks.
Cue The music,
young Jamie,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast all day.
I've been a fan of,
worked for a long time,
man.
So it's great to have you on.
I really a,
I enjoy your show.
I enjoy what you're doing.
And I enjoy that there's this outlet now where you don't have to go through a
million different steps and get approved by producers.
She just create your own show.
It's relevant.
It's interesting.
It's engaging.
People tune in and then all of a sudden,
boom,
look at that.
You're the number one news show on the Internet.
I mean,
that's pretty crazy.
Yeah,
it's totally crazy.
Thanks for saying all that.
It's uh,
it's,
it's been a crazy,
crazy ride,
you know?
Uh,
and I love doing a podcast here because it reminds me of how we started and we
literally started my living room and we're about to hit like 2 billion views and
it's 2 billion.
Yeah,
it's madness.
What year did you start?
Uh,
2002 we started doing,
sending in taped shows to Sirius satellite radio.
Wow.
We were actually serious his first original talk show.
Well that's incredible.
So what was,
what was the thought process behind it?
Like you just said,
you know what,
I don't,
nothing out there is representing my point of view.
Let me just create something.
Yeah.
Okay.
So first,
let me just quickly say thanks for having me on and thanks.
[inaudible] never gone on anything,
TV,
anything where people were more excited that I was going to come on someplace.
Really.
Wow.
Well we've spoken highly of you and your show many times on it,
so thank you man.
A lot of people that are connected here.
Yeah,
I appreciate that.
So,
um,
I initially for like three and a half minutes,
I was a lawyer and I hated that.
Couldn't stand it.
So,
um,
well a friend of mine suggested I take like a course on how to start your own TV
show.
I was like,
that's mental,
that's not,
you can't do that.
Right.
And so I went to a learning annex course in New York,
uh,
and these lady just took our money and said,
hey,
schmucks,
go to your local public access.
You could start any show you're like,
right.
That's it.
That was the whole thing.
And so I was like,
okay,
I still don't believe it.
I went to first day of the law at the law firm,
I left early to go to orientation at a public access station.
Okay.
And I went there and you know,
you've got to go through this whole process,
get trained up,
Yada Yada.
First Time I go on air,
uh,
we did an hour long show with me and my friends,
half of what it was on politics,
half was it,
half of it was on philosophy.
Okay.
Like we had to philosophical debates on God and all that stuff and everybody
else was bored to tears.
I walked off the stage thinking that's what I'm doing.
God,
I love that.
That's what I'm doing the rest of my life.
Wow.
So I got started there.
Then God like barged my way into local radio.
W Rko in Boston,
WWE RC in Washington,
just weekends fill in whatever they'd give me.
I drive nine hours to Boston to do weekend show.
Uh,
and then,
and then I went to Miami and got on TV.
Same thing like bars.
My weigh in,
started in sales,
worked my way up,
somehow got on air,
somehow became the supervising producer of their flagship show and Onair
commentator.
And then that got sold.
I was Barry Diller's group and then I came out to la and I started a writing
cause that's what my main job,
I at the TV station,
it had become head writer for the show.
And so then I was wrote on three different pilots here in la.
And I remember when I,
the star,
like the straw that broke the camel's back on that was,
I was writing for daisy for when tess and they're like okay now you need to use
Daisy's voice.
And I was like,
I don't know what daisy is.
Fucking boy.
She's,
I don't know that at all.
I've never met her and I don't want to be Daisy's voice.
I want to be my voice.
So I was like,
I got to get back into radio cause that's the only place they let you do a talk
show it.
That's back in o two right.
Oh one actually at that time.
And so I called up my old friends one who was a program director,
wr Rko in Boston who den gone to Xm.
He's like Cenk Dude,
you got to go to serious right now that they just opened the door,
go,
I'll put in a recommendation for you.
And basically like bars my way in there started the young Turks.
What we know now is the young Turks,
I started with Ben who was the anchor at the station in Miami that I was working
with and they literally didn't even know we were on the air for the first six
months.
And then when they found out they were like,
Oh shit,
now we've got to pay you
it didn't know you were on the air.
Uh,
because some consultant had hired us and then when they eventually hired a
program director for talk,
cause we're the first talk shit.
They didn't even have a program director for that.
And then they hired one and they're like,
oh right,
right.
These guys are on there.
Okay,
what should we do with them?
And he had me go into New York and he sat me down and listen to some tapes.
He's like,
you guys are surprisingly decent.
All right,
fuck it.
We'll pay.
And that's how we got started.
Are you guys still on exit and well now it's serious NSM,
right?
Right.
Combined.
No,
we were on there for a million years,
but honestly the video online video got so much bigger than radio.
Then it became not worth it.
Like even for the minor hassle of like doing formatting,
doing three hours,
we're like it's not worth it.
So we just let it go.
Do you guys have a a podcast version of it or an audible download version of it?
Yeah,
so on Itunes we got a free audio podcasts and a free video podcast that's like
two out of the six segments we do every day.
So people can sample it.
It's not bad actually.
That's already like,
well probably more than half an hour of content for free.
And then if you're a hardcore and you liked the show,
then you just go to our website TYT network.com and it's a $10 membership.
And so then you get all of it,
you get the main show,
you get all the network shows,
you get everything.
So if anybody wanted to,
they can get plenty of free content,
but you do so much stuff that if you want to be,
so what percentage of the people that like,
like get to it and start downloading it.
Do you know like what percentage actually sign up?
You have a huge amount of subscribers,
right?
So on Youtube,
uh,
we,
we have a little over one and a half million subscribers for the young Turks to
flagship show for the whole network we have,
but I think about 3 million subscribers.
You know,
when you have all of our shows like pop trigger or what the flick,
which is movie reviews,
TYT sports,
stuff like that.
But,
um,
and we have 64 million views a month on the network,
24 million uniques every month.
But when you talking about people paying 10 bucks a month,
we almost never advertise it,
which is so stupid of us,
partly because we had troubles with the website and stuff.
Uh,
the people who pay the 10 bucks,
that's around four to 5,000
still though.
Wow.
It's amazing.
So you've,
you've essentially set up your own studio.
You have your own network.
I mean it's,
it's not just a show now you have like this entire thing you've developed.
Are you,
you're only on some of those shows too,
right?
There's gang of other people working for you.
Yeah.
So there's 29 channels.
So if I was on all those shows,
my head would explode.
My head's about to explode as it is to run on the network and being on the show.
And then I,
for three years,
I did TV at the same time,
which was just so crazy.
It was just,
I was going to melt down.
My body was breaking down.
Um,
but yeah,
all those channels,
a great host.
We got 30 people that are full time.
But then if you add all the hosts that are not full time to it,
then you're talking probably 50,
60 people.
That's insane.
Yeah.
And we all,
we literally started in our living room,
like when,
hey Susie,
who's still with us,
12 years later,
walked in as an intern.
He was like,
okay,
there's like a 12% chance I'm getting murdered today.
This is this guy's living room.
And it's kind of scary looking
and I can't believe he stuck with us,
but he did.
Now we've got this big studio space in Culver City and we're producing shows
like there's no tomorrow.
Wow.
And you guys recently,
did you use Kickstarter or something to fund your,
your studio?
What did,
how did you set that up?
What'd you do?
We did Indeigogo um,
so it's basically the same thing as Kickstarter.
And um,
we like it a little better.
And we thought,
all right,
uh,
we need money to build the new studio because we had been with current
television and they had paid our rent.
Why this great deal with them where I,
they paid me to be a host.
They paid some of our producers and they paid for the rent.
Great deal.
Uh,
so when we left,
when they got bought by Al Jazeera and we didn't want to be without just
Jazeera.
So then we got to go build our own studio,
which is incredibly expensive.
So we were like,
okay,
let's try this because you know,
we built everything with our audience.
Let's try to build this with them.
And I remember we sat around in a room and there was like six,
seven of us were like,
what?
What should we go for?
And every single person agreed 150,000 like,
let's go for it.
Let's go nuts.
Let's try to get 150,000.
So then it came back around to me and I was like,
okay,
that sounds good.
Uh,
we're going to go for two 50.
Okay.
Because I'd rather get to try for two 15 and get to one 75 and then people are
like,
oh,
you didn't make it.
I'm like,
yeah,
but I've got an extra 25,000 I didn't expect.
So that's awesome.
You know,
I don't give a care what people say as long as we can actually use the money to
build a studio.
Anyway.
It turns out we got basically a little over
$400,000.
Whoa.
That's incredible.
But that's just a sign that what you're doing resonates.
So that's gotta be,
that's gotta be very fulfilling.
That's got to feel nice.
Yeah.
You know,
so my dad,
uh,
is a guy who like,
we'll focus on the positive for about a second and a half and then he'll be
like,
okay,
yeah,
but let me tell you all the things that are going wrong and Yada Yada.
So I've unfortunately internalize that.
I mean,
it's got a good aspect to it in a bad aspect,
but so like I never take a moment to be like,
yes,
right.
I a little bit,
when we did the billion views party,
we did that a youtube space and I was like,
dude,
billions.
Kind of a hard number to deny,
right?
Like if you talk,
I'm like soup.
Like in some ways I'm humble because I think I failed so much in my life that
it's impossible not to be humble.
Right.
But in other ways,
I'm a massive ego maniac.
But even when we started,
if you told this EGOMANIAC,
we're going a billion views,
I'd be like,
dude,
come on,
bounce a recent.
Right.
That's not going to happen.
That's crazy talk.
So then I soaked it in a little bit.
Yeah.
And when the audience delivered and it was over 400,000,
that was another moment.
Like,
just like you said,
it wasn't the money as much and the money was great,
but it w it was more like,
man,
they really,
they believe in us,
man.
And it,
and that comes with a responsibility is,
you know,
Spiderman,
his uncle told him with great power,
great responsibility.
That was before he left the crook.
Killed By.
Yeah.
Uncle.
Well,
what you're doing is what people have wanted to see for a while.
Someone who has,
uh,
it's,
it's an opinion straight from the source.
It's not filtered by the networks,
by the executives,
by all these people that have measured statistics and looked at numbers and
decided this is the approach that would best suit them.
And you know,
we take need to take the fox girls and their skirts should be one inch shorter
than it is right now.
We've shown that we can get an extra 1 million views a month if we have more
leg.
You know what you're doing is,
this is my name is Janke [inaudible].
This is my opinion.
Boom.
I'm going to put it out there and I don't give a fuck what you think.
And that is what everybody is always wanted because what you're getting when you
listen to the nightly news today on Wall Street,
we learned you're getting a fake voice with a guy who is reading off a
teleprompter with a,
a gang of people that their objective is just about making money and about
producing this program,
this business that's called the news.
And so what their,
their objective is not getting information out to people.
Their objective is not debating the hard facts.
It's not rabble rousing.
It's not telling people like,
we better wake up and fucking realize what's going on here.
It's none of that.
There's none of that.
But you come along and that is exactly what you're doing.
And then,
and then people start going,
hey,
look at this,
look at this.
There's another thing going on over here.
This guy's got this thing and he's using the Internet and woo the Internet.
Oh my God,
nobody could tell him what to do.
No,
nobody's telling you what to do.
This is his opinion.
And then it takes off.
And that's,
that's a very important thing that in my opinion,
sort of embodies or personifies this time in our culture.
It's a very unique time.
And that,
that ability that we have now to just freely express ourselves.
And you know,
you could become one of those people.
Like there's,
I,
I found out this guy the other day online,
some science podcast and he has on youtube or some science show on Youtube.
Somebody told me,
hey,
you should check this out.
I looked at it.
Each video is like 17 million views,
6 million views.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
How many of those fucking guys are there now?
You've just find out about them and already they have millions and millions and
millions of subscribers.
This is,
there's never been a time like that.
There's never been a time like we're experiencing today.
Yeah.
You know,
I think our successes is bigger than us.
It's not about us.
Right.
Just like you said,
it's about a certain period of time in,
in the history of media that uh,
in,
in essence what they've done is the mainstream media has handed us like 80% of
the market just by their abject failure.
You know,
so you turn on TV and it's wall to wall fakeness and it's guys reading from a
prompter.
It's guys who are supposed to be reporters that never asked followup questions
cause they don't actually know the material that they're producers write out the
questions ahead of time.
I've been there.
Right.
They did write out the questions ahead of time.
They read it.
They're,
they're not news anchors.
Their news actors.
That's great.
Wait describing them.
And so,
and then they got that fake voice that you're talking about.
I mean like what is that?
Why,
why do they talk like that?
Like I remember,
this is a story I told him on the show once and I'm in New Orleans for Mardi
Gras,
were,
were pretty fucked up.
And then we turned on the TV and it's a normal local news lady and she's like,
and a number of ambulance has doubled,
but so has the number of injuries.
Why,
why are you seeing it like that?
It's really weird.
Like if anybody in real life talk like that,
you'd be like that.
That's they're tripping.
There's something wrong with them.
This two parallels.
There's a top 40 Dj and the Strip club Dj,
those,
those are also fake voices that they adopt that are uniquely,
uh,
like attached to that job.
Yeah.
And so when I was in radio,
people were like,
dude,
you're mental.
You're going to keep the name Jank.
Ugur and,
and the chank is spelled with a c in the beginning.
They're like,
you're nuts,
dude.
Jack Unger,
Jake Underwood,
who cares?
Who Cares?
Right.
And I even once ran into gene Simmons at some local La and new station here.
And we were both in the green room and he's like,
oh,
you're the dumbest guy I've ever met who keeps a name like Janky rigor.
Okay.
He's like,
yeah,
you just make up a name.
Gene Simmons made up,
kisses made up,
keep it simple stupid.
Okay.
And so he yelled at me.
But what it turned out to be is kind of an ironic advantage because there's no
way Janky yogurt isn't real.
Right?
Right.
That's,
that's my real name.
It's a pain in the ass,
but I'm not fake like everybody else on TV and radio.
And I'm not going to
like every,
doesn't everybody want to say fuck you to that guy?
Yeah,
I think we do.
Now we also want to say fuck you to politicians that talk like that too.
When do you think there's going to be a time where we get a guy who talks in a
political speech like that?
Like you like a guy who just,
who comes along and says,
you know what,
Ladies and gentlemen,
the United States that we know today,
this great nation,
that we're tired of,
that we're tired of these weird pauses.
We're tired of weird theatrical presentation,
you know,
we,
we would like someone who's running for president,
who's running for any office,
Congress,
whatever,
just talk,
talk,
wearing a fucking normal human being.
You could talk with passion,
you could talk with energy,
you could talk with,
with,
with a real engaging sense of the present and still be you.
You don't have to be this fucking strip club Dj.
Oh ride on the main stage.
That same voice is repeated throughout the trip clubs all across America.
I did this recent thing where I was calling in,
um,
uh,
a bunch of radio stations because of a comedy central special that I had,
that it was coming out.
And when I'm calling in to talk to them,
there was three or four stations where I'm like,
okay,
this fucking guy,
I'm talking to the exact guy,
he's just using a different voice and now he's in Memphis,
you know,
and now he's in Dallas and now he's in Ohio.
It's fucking crazy.
Like they adopt that same fake voice.
We,
you know,
I think we need,
we need to change.
We certainly need a change in,
in the way information is being broadcasted to people.
And that's a start.
So this Saturday we held a debate for the 33rd congressional district.
Henry Waxman is retiring.
And so there's like 15 people running in,
12 of them showed up at the [inaudible] studios.
It's a US congressional seat.
And it's funny,
the guys who had the,
like we're higher up in the polls were the guys who unfortunately like more
polished but polished meant like they like point to you like this,
they don't want to use a single finger,
they do the Bill Clinton point or they do this and then they talk and talking
points.
But what was cool is that like nine out of 12 guys weren't like that.
And then you're like,
oh wow.
A political debate where that guy's an actual human being.
And so when the guy with the talking point talked,
it sounded weird,
right?
Like,
hey,
why are you using that voice?
That's weird.
So it was an interesting contrast.
Yeah.
And,
and I think people got to find,
and I did follow up questions,
so they'd do their talk like you,
you know how in a debate you ask a question and then they'll just answer it any
way they like,
right.
That's what Sarah Pailin realized.
She was super nervous about debating Biden and then realized,
oh right,
I don't have to actually answer any of the questions.
So she memorized what she was going to say about x number of topics and that's
how she got through the debate.
So that's what they were doing.
And then I was like,
oh,
that's interesting.
Okay.
Now the question I asked was actually this.
Okay,
so what's your release?
And so that was,
I dunno,
maybe we can change that too.
Well,
I think that that you saw that a lot in the early days of standup comedy,
there was a lot of guys who had like the standup comedy,
like a way of talking.
It was almost like a,
an effected thing that everybody borrowed when they went to do standup comedy.
And then as people started getting better,
you sort of dropped that and became more of yourself.
But I think in a,
in a great sense,
politicians don't have that luxury of,
you know,
so they,
they try to sort of connect with what they think is the most effective voice
possible.
And that voice is the voice that sort of in their head represents
professionalism.
Yup.
That's it.
It's so weird term.
Right?
Professionalism's a weird term because you want someone to be dedicated.
He wants someone to be focused and disciplined,
but you don't want to fucking professional and the last place you want to
professional as a politician.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So two things about that.
I talked to a consultant was a political consultant and he said,
look,
Jank part of the reason we give them the talking points and try to keep them on
message and make them sound robotic is because you'd be surprised how stupid
there.
And he's like,
and if we just let them talk,
they will make terrible mistakes and they will lose.
One of my favorite moments at all
politics is the Rick Perry moment.
We forgot what he was talking about.
I forgot some points.
Yeah.
And then he goes to kills.
I don't remember the other ones.
That's a dude.
You're done.
He just tapped out.
I mean,
he really did just tap out.
Yeah.
He literally said in that debate,
like he forgot pause,
pause,
like the most wonderful,
awkward five seconds in any debate.
And then like he said,
oops.
That.
And then there's a homeboy from Vermont,
uh,
what's his name?
Who was screaming and that and that Howard Dean,
Howard Dean where it crushed him.
One,
one,
one yell,
and it tanked the whole thing.
Well,
he see
point.
He'd already lost Iowa.
I actually really liked Howard Dean or I used to do as well.
Right.
Um,
so he,
that was after he'd lost the big race,
so he probably would have lost anyway.
And I think what really put a hatchet in him was,
was the media.
Like they didn't,
they didn't want a guy who was an actual,
like independent and rebellious,
et cetera.
They wanted someone super boring and dull who was totally pro Salish shrink,
just like John Kerry.
So they lean heavily and Kerry's direction and look at,
some people will go further and say,
oh,
they immediate manufacturer does scream.
No they didn't.
I remember,
and we covered it on the young Turks were like,
Oh shit,
we lit.
We really liked the guy,
but he sounded like a maniac,
right?
Well folks who don't know,
and when you're in a large audience like that and you're,
you're yelling into a microphone,
you don't usually have a monitor or anything in your ear.
So you don't know how you sound too.
When someone's,
something's broadcast directly into a microphone.
That microphone is going directly into the recording device.
And it's very different than what you're hearing when you're yelling.
So if a bunch of people are screaming like,
and we're going to go straight to the White House,
you're,
you're yelling this where there's thousands of people also yelling.
There's an overwhelming amount of sound.
But what goes into that microphone is connected to your face,
stupid.
And it's,
it's loud as fuck.
And people are gonna hear this maniacal screech that comes of you,
and it's not going to be in perspective.
It's not going to be in the perspective of the actual rally itself.
Yeah.
And look,
whether it's media or politics,
oftentimes people make the mistake of playing to the room instead of people
watching.
Right.
And there's so many more people watching at home than there are people in that
room.
So that's why politicians keep getting caught on tape because they're not used
to the youtube generation.
So like they'll go into a room full of funders and they'll be like,
oh,
it doesn't the 47% suck.
Haha,
screw the poor.
Then they'll go to another room with other people and say the exact opposite and
they'll just keep going room to room saying things that don't make that don't
match up.
But dude,
like hello,
catch up to 2014 everything's on tape.
And then you'll play the two tapes next to each other and it,
and they look like assholes.
And that's because they're used to playing to just whoever's in the room.
Yeah.
They're used to playing to just whoever's in the room.
And they're not used to the repercussions of the truth getting out there because
the slide,
it's an escapable.
And I,
I personally think there's this lack of privacy comes with a lot of concerns.
A lot of people worried,
a lot of people,
they,
they look at the future and they say,
well,
we're not going to have any privacy anymore.
Yeah.
But ultimately I think that the truth,
it's,
it's more beneficial that people have complete total transparency across the
board than it is for people to engage in the same sort of corrupt activities
that have turned this nation into this.
It's,
it's basically a bought and sold system and there's no other way to get past
that bought and sold system.
Then ultimate complete,
total transparency.
And when you have that ultimate complete total transparency,
which we're starting to see manifest itself in politics and in social media.
And no,
this is a kind of across the board.
It's a slow,
steady progression to no secrets and sorry,
but that's just the way of the world.
That's,
it's going that way.
You could be moaning,
you could scream at the top of your lungs.
I'm moving to the woods,
I'm going to live off of fucking logs and I'm gonna have my own well water,
you can do that.
But everybody in the cities,
everybody in the congested centers of population centers there,
they're not going to have secrets anymore.
It's just gonna be just like if someone was in China,
you used to not be able to call them on the phone.
Well you can now cause that's what happened.
And in the future there's not going to be any secrets man.
And so if you're running for politics or if you're running for a political
office and you want to say shit like 47% of people aren't going to vote for him
anyway,
so fuck them.
People got to know that.
That's your real attitude.
You're not going to be able to hide your attitude.
I think that's great because I don't believe that there's bad people out there
that it's only bad people that run for office.
It's only bad people that can get into office.
It's only bad people that run companies.
I think you allow bad people to run companies,
bad people that run corporations because of the fact there's no transparency
because they don't face repercussions for environmental damage for,
you know,
employing Third World Country People in Third World countries for a fucking
dollar a month.
We,
all those repercussions are going to be all on the table now and it's not going
to be a simple,
so two things about that.
One great example of it is,
uh,
today with Donald Sterling,
like,
so he does his apology that they're going to broadcast on CNN tonight.
And if you,
for the transcript that they released the parts that,
the excerpts that I saw,
he never apologized to black people.
He apologizes to the other NBA owners and he says,
you know,
once in 35 years,
uh,
I did a slip up and it's just one mistake.
Can they find a way to forgive that?
What he's saying is I slipped up in letting you know how I actually think like,
so he hates transparency and he's like,
God dammit.
Like they caught me once,
but like he doesn't get that.
No,
no,
no.
It's your mentality.
That's the problem.
Like,
and because they're so used to being like,
I own the clippers,
I'm uh,
you know,
multimillionaire,
you,
you don't get to know anything about me and I could be in his racist as I,
like,
I could cover it up,
et cetera.
So that this new world is shaking them up and they can't get used to,
they can't wrap their mind around it.
And he keeps thinking like,
why can't I just take that back?
And then everybody goes back to not realizing I'm a racist.
So,
so that's part of it.
The other part is that we've got this split right where you have television and
radio and all that,
that's super fake.
And then you have the new media,
like your podcast,
like what we do online with video that's super real and it's a fascinating
clash.
And old media hates us.
Like they don't,
they don't want to acknowledge for real,
like w even like people that work in media,
they're,
when they're covering it,
like when we say,
okay,
we got this many views,
et cetera,
they're Google verified.
Go check with Google.
They're like,
ah,
I can,
I don't know.
I can't understand Internet numbers.
Well then maybe you shouldn't do that
again.
There's then the Internet numbers,
the Internet numbers,
the only numbers that are real when you look at us,
right?
If you look at numbers like the ratings for a television show,
if anybody who knows how television shows a ratings,
it's Voodoo.
It's crazy.
There's like,
I don't know how many thousand boxes that are supposed to represent 300 plus
million people,
but it's nonsense.
Those Nielsen ratings are fucking crazy.
Like they really don't know.
Not only that,
the reality of the difference between the Nielsen ratings and the ratings that
they've pulled from digital boxes from dvrs from Saturday,
it's a very different number.
It's a very different number and there's a lot of shows that would benefit from
them releasing the numbers that are on a Dvr is the numbers are on a satellite
boxes and cable boxes,
but they can't really do that because they can't acknowledge,
first of all the fact that they keep track of what everybody's watching it all
the time.
And then also like the digital,
the Nielsen system,
it's like a established system that people in benefiting from from a long time
until like throw that out and shake it up with millions dollars would change
hands.
See that's a huge advantage for us though because we can tell them exactly what
they're doing wrong and they can say,
Hey Joe Jank you're right.
That's,
but they can't turn the ship around because they were,
they already make too much money doing what they do and yes,
they're killing off their audience.
Yes.
Eventually they'll hit that iceberg and sink so quick.
Right.
But they can't stop doing what they're doing cause their ship is too damn big
and they can't turn it around.
So Hey,
Saturday for them.
Isn't that sort of the same thing with politics as well and with corporations as
well.
It's like what they've done for the longest time is just that's how they extract
money.
That's how they get money out of the system.
That's what they do.
And for the longest time they've done it this way and just to put a pause on it
and sort of reshuffle and redistribute where the money's going,
it's like,
fuck,
that's too hard.
We're just going to crash into the rocks.
Let's just ride this bitch right into the beach,
hit the rocks,
the boat will shatter,
we'll get off.
Whoever survives survives,
we'll make a new boat.
Yeah,
it seems like that's what they're doing.
So two things about that now.
First on the radio end,
do you know how they do radio ratings?
Because it'll blow your mind,
but Tron,
yeah,
those books to send out to people and they were,
what were you listening to?
Oh,
this,
yeah.
I mean,
of course,
99% of the population doesn't know how they get the radio ratings and they send
out these books and you have to fill it out for three months.
What were you listening in 15 minute increments.
So,
and everybody fills it out at the very end when they have to turn it in.
So they're like,
okay.
Um,
month and a half ago at 2:15 PM I dunno,
I think I was listening to rush.
I Dunno.
Did they pay them to fill those books out?
I think like five bucks.
So there's like,
so they're just like,
give me the five bucks.
I don't care.
Like it was a comical comical,
right?
How low that they pay.
So,
so everybody makes it up.
So like th the radio numbers are pure fiction,
pure fiction.
So then that was the old days.
Now they're going to people meters,
which is a little bit more accurate.
And then when they went to people meet her,
they're like,
oh my God,
nobody listens to rush Limbaugh.
Nobody.
Sean Hannity,
Glenn Beck,
nobody listens to them.
And are the numbers like what's the difference?
What they thought was so,
yeah.
So first of all,
the number that rush Limbaugh used to go with was he threw out a number of the
fake number.
It just broadcasting,
right?
His fake number was 20 million.
Nobody ever questioned where he got that number.
Nobody even knows if it's per week or per month.
Right?
It's not funny.
Like what do you mean?
That's,
that's a big difference.
He's like 20 million.
That's it.
Okay.
And then talkers magazine did a bullshit guests and they're like,
hmm,
14 million.
Okay.
First of all,
difference between 14 and 20 is pretty substantial,
but it doesn't really matter.
So reporter asked the Michael Harrison Photography magazine,
he's like,
where'd you get the 14 million?
He's like,
I guess
they don't know it all.
So I,
you know,
the difference per market between what rush claim to be getting and then what he
got in the people meters.
That level of,
I don't know.
I do know the w ABC in New York,
which is the main conservative talk station,
is thinking of changing the format because that's how disastrous it was.
Glenn Beck loss to like San Francisco or Philly and Philly,
I think immediately,
um,
soon as they found out the real number,
right?
Uh,
and Sean Hannity is in a tailspin,
so they still got money to milk from that system.
You know,
they still have their contracts that lasts for x number of years,
right?
But they're on their way out.
So those numbers are super fake.
That compared to that.
Now when you go tell a old media writer,
whatever name it,
you know,
New York Times,
whatever,
CNN,
and you say young Turks is bigger than rush Limbaugh,
they'll laugh you out of the room.
No Way.
They believe that.
Right?
But the reality is he's nowhere near 14 million listeners a month.
Nowhere near it.
And we're Google verified 24 million uniques,
let alone 64 million views,
right?
We're at least twice as large as rush limbo.
But nobody like,
but no,
let it go.
There's no media hype behind you.
There's no promotion that you will,
you got to,
I got to you from my internet message board.
Just complete word of mouth.
Somebody threw up a video,
check this out.
You know,
I don't,
I don't even remember what was the original thing,
but I remember,
oh,
this is a cool show.
Oh,
I get it.
Boom.
And then I started listening and paying attention and that's how you spread.
Whereas you know,
if you,
if it's rushed,
limbo,
excellence in broadcasting or Sean Hannity mean there's a whole fucking machine
behind these things and there's a whole,
I mean it's a part of the thing.
The Sean Hannity thing is particularly disturbing to me because what he
represents to me is like this sort of consolidated ignorance,
like this decision to be ignorant about things.
Like we're,
we're,
we're on the right,
we're in,
we're right wing and we're going to stick with what is American flag behind me
and God bless our troops and cut to commercial and this,
this,
this sort of agreement to not delve into the nuances of very difficult topics
and to,
you know,
to take a hard stance towards the right.
I think that's like one of the most damaging things about the whole paradigm of
the right.
And the left is this hard line,
you know,
almost a religious acceptance of one side or the other.
And it was really personified with Hannity.
Well,
a bunch of things.
But recently by this Bundy ranch incident,
this fucking crazy ass hole in Nevada that these shitheads got behind.
This guy is fucking crazy.
He's crazy.
And he says a bunch of Nutty,
racist shit.
Like black people were better off when they were slaves on the plantation
because now I go to Vegas and I see them running around and they know they're
not going to school and they're getting each other pregnant.
Like,
what?
What you fucking take time off of your ranch.
You drive through a bad neighborhood in Vegas and you decide you've got to
fucking a synopsis of black people.
Like,
Holy Shit,
this is the guy you fucking people got behind a guy who's this nutty fuck was
letting his cows roam all over the place eating grass.
He doesn't want to pay for it.
Like it's,
it's bizarre.
It's a very bizarre thing.
But they saw him,
they saw this Bundy character as sort of this poster guy for,
uh,
you know,
the America that's
fed up with the intrusion of the federal government into our lives and the
Socialist Obama network.
And Hannity jumps on board with this and now it just looks like a complete
fucking idiot when more and more of this information comes out about this guy.
So he says black people,
but Bundy does black people mooching off the government.
Dude,
you owe the government 1 million bucks
a lot more than that.
It was like 9 million or something crazy like that.
So like more than a decade,
right.
The whole point of this controversy is that you're mooching off the government a
lot more than a welfare person.
Right.
And he like literally a million times before there was ever a person.
And then imagine if the situation was reversed,
like they decide that they're not going to pay their taxes and Compton reversed
racially,
right?
And then they're like,
oh,
if the government,
he comes here to collect the taxes,
fees,
whatever,
all the black folks in Compton and grab their guns and then they're going to
point them at the federal government and make 'em back down.
What do you think Hannity's reaction to that would have been like,
ah,
new Black Panther party destroying the country.
Obama use,
how can he do this?
These are good honest cops and your due date or respect authority and all of
these black people in their guns are dangerous.
Right?
White militia shows up with guns.
Fuck the federal government.
It's fascinating.
Yeah,
it is fascinating.
And those people that did show up,
I,
you know,
I the,
the real problem with any of those subjects is that people have this sort of
knee jerk side.
Did they take this knee jerk reaction they take,
you see a bunch of cops with dogs and they're telling us rancher and you think
of a rancher as a farmer,
you think of a farmer is America the backbone of America?
Guy was farming,
you know,
but this is a lot going on here.
This is a,
this is a big fucking long complicated tale and you can't,
you can't describe it in five minutes and you can't break it down to a guy like
Sean Hannity that has a billion other fucking things on his mind.
He just sees it as a category.
Oh,
it's on the right,
right.
Support White people.
Yeah.
They don't want the Obama,
we've got a black president and fuck yeah,
run with it.
You know,
it's like,
it's this really complex issue that they just shuffle in and it kind of
highlights why that system sucks.
I mean it's one of the best stories.
One of the best recent stories to highlight why this,
this right left paradigm on,
on television really suck six.
So one of my big surprises when I got into the talk show world was how stupid
Sean Hannity's.
And honestly,
because like when I went in,
I was like,
I thought,
okay,
look,
if I get make it on TV and I might have to debate like somebody like Sean
Hannity,
I got to really come correct,
right.
I got to make sure that I've got all my information,
etc. And then as I heard him throughout the years,
I'd be like,
wait,
those two cloths are not connected that there was no logical nexus.
Right.
I'm like,
and then I realize,
oh my God,
he's just going from one talking point to another.
He's another news actor,
but he's paid to be like conservative Republican propaganda news actor.
He's just reading the shit.
He's just,
he knows like he never makes logical sense.
It's like you could be republican or you could be conservative like Ron Paul.
He makes sense like you agree or disagree,
but he,
you go,
okay,
I understand the logical jumps he's making here,
and he's like,
no,
this is my talking point on how I hate Obama.
The next thing sounds like the exact opposite,
but it's still talking boy and about,
I hate Obama,
and so I was like,
Oh wow,
these guys are dumb.
Oh,
this is going to be easy.
I don't know if it's dumb as much as it's not thought out.
It's,
it's,
there's no,
there's a,
there's also no motivation to be like open minded or objective or look at it
from a different angle.
The motivation has to fall into a category that's easy to profit off.
Yeah.
So you're right.
And they get paid to be on a certain team.
I mean,
look,
I went through that at Msnbc and so
what was that like?
Cause that you're uniquely qualified to discuss this,
right?
Cause he'd been behind the scenes.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
and,
and just to be clear,
they're not all dumb and bill O'Reilly and he's a really smart guy,
you know,
agree or disagree.
I mean,
that guy knows how to do broadcasts.
Tide comes in,
the tide comes out.
You can't explain.
You can't explain that.
Not one of his top moments.
Maybe it is because maybe he shows what he's doing.
He's playing all this fucking monkeys out there that agree with them just
sucking money out of their accounts.
But at least he knows how to play to them.
Right.
So he's bright in that sense.
Unlike Hannah Day thing.
So Repo,
so the guys on the right,
they are writing a certain gravy train,
right.
Whether it's a conservative talk guys or the Fox News guys.
And you can't get off that gravy train because I remember when we were first
starting out,
uh,
sent my,
our tape,
the young Turks tape to a station in Minnesota and guys like,
I loved it,
the program director.
I'm like,
oh great.
So what are you thinking?
What time slot?
And he's like,
no,
no time slot.
I said,
why?
He said,
everyone we have here is conservative on there.
I can't,
they'll,
if I put you on the air people,
my audience will hate you and then they will hate me.
Right?
So if you want to be on this station,
you have to be conservative.
So if those guys had a genuine change of opinion,
right?
Well they did lose their jobs because they couldn't be on that station anymore.
You see what I'm saying?
So if you're a local guy in Minnesota doing conservative talk,
you have to keep doing conservative talk,
otherwise you can't feed your family.
There is no liberal talk station,
you know,
especially back then,
then there was,
now there's a couple left around.
So that's one reason why they stay on the team that they're in and they are not
interested in listening to your ideas.
Now what I was at Msnbc as I found out,
it turns out they were team Democrat and it's one thing to be conservatives and
the ad or to be progressive.
I think that's totally fine.
The Nation is a progressive magazine.
That's who they are,
right?
Um,
we're progressive.
That's who we are,
but we're not on team Democrat.
Uh,
like,
so if a Democrat is not doing something progressive,
we're going to call them out.
To me that's like obvious.
I don't even,
I had trouble comprehending that other people didn't think that way.
Right.
To them cares what your ideas are,
man.
Who killed your principals?
What are you talking about?
Right,
right.
No,
no,
no.
This is team Democrat and you stay on this team.
So I mean,
I don't know if he ever heard the story,
but like the,
the reason I left Msnbc is I got a speech from the head of the network,
Phil Griffin,
who said,
hey,
look man,
I love to be an outsider.
Outsiders wear leather jackets,
they ride motorcycles,
they're super cool.
But
I'm like,
oh,
I didn't know that.
I've never written a motorcycle.
Most guys,
they kind of scare me,
but I said,
yeah.
He said,
but this is NBC,
right?
Were insiders,
and I was just in Washington.
They're not happy with your tone and we're the establishment here and you got to
start acting like it.
Wow.
Amazing.
It's not just amazing.
It's like a scene in a movie.
Exactly.
That's what I always say.
I felt like I was at a movie and I was like,
I'm like,
dude.
And maybe maybe he got off on that.
Maybe he felt like
he was in a movie and he was going to give this big speech.
Right.
But as I talked to,
I don't want to name the person,
but I talked to another anchor that was there and that we had lunch and that
person was like,
why did he say that to you?
Like that's such a,
you're supposed to be more subtle
than that.
Like that was such a stupid thing to say.
And especially you,
you came out of the Internet,
you,
the whole thing is like truth telling and being super progressive.
Why did he say that to you?
And not even give you a raise?
Why he's telling you the way to do it is to say,
listen,
we're in,
you're an insider.
So here's,
I have a new package for you.
Right?
And this packages,
you know,
shares and this and see Joe,
that's,
you nailed it.
You nailed it.
Because that's what came next.
No.
Okay.
So,
so in that speech,
uh,
I'm,
I've been working at Msnbc as a host and then Keith urban leaves,
they give me the six o'clock slot,
right?
And I'm on there from January to April.
Okay.
At that point,
April,
I get the speech and I think to myself,
fuck that,
I'm not doing that.
Right.
I will go the opposite direction.
I'll criticize Obama more.
I'll criticized the Democrats more,
right?
Because I don't want to play their game.
And then like get mediocre ratings.
And then they say you got,
so I turned it on between April and the beginning of July.
I'm murdered in the ratings,
highest ratings they ever got at six o'clock.
Okay.
Cause I was more me.
And so like in stylistically I listened to them.
They would say like be more senatorial.
I'm like,
why would you want to do that?
My sits or senators or the most boring people I've ever met.
Why would you want to do that?
Right.
That's crazy.
Anyway,
so,
uh,
I open it up and then at the end of June,
Phil calls me back in two to your point.
Right.
And he's like Jank um,
we decided we're going to put you on the weekends.
Not on prime time.
It's six.
Okay.
And when you give that to somebody else,
I was like,
oh that's interesting.
Like I thought I was prepared for it because I had gotten the speech a couple of
months earlier about kind of,
yeah.
And I knew that's when I was like,
I'm done with this.
Right.
Like if they want to keep me cause I got a kickass readings,
great.
I'd love it.
Okay.
As long as they let me say what I'm going to say.
If they don't want to keep me,
fuck.
Okay.
So he pulls me in and I said,
okay,
fill.
So let's go through a quick exercise.
Here are my ratings.
Good lollies.
Can't deny it.
They're,
yeah,
they're the best they've gotten at six.
Yeah,
they're great.
I'm like,
is anybody,
am I dick?
Like is anybody in the building said Hey genx and dig.
So he's hard to work with,
right?
Nope.
Great.
Like everybody likes you in the building,
right?
Yeah.
And every like great relationships,
right?
Um,
I said,
so if you put me on the weekends and it's not related to the speech,
right,
then how would I ever get out of the weekends,
right?
Like within,
what is it related to like Efi murdered on the weekends.
I already murdered a six o'clock right on the rating,
so we can't,
and I saw,
I said,
what is it?
And he stood there for about 30 seconds without any answer.
And I was like,
wow.
And then he said,
I'll double your seller.
Oh,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
I'll double your salary.
But what,
I'll double your salary and put you on the weekends still.
Yes.
So you go from prime time to weekends,
but they offered me literally double my salary and for three year contract,
so they thought there's no way I'm going to turn that kind of money down.
Like I've been a struggling radio hosts and then internet host my whole life at
that point.
Right.
There's no way I'm going to turn that down and you know,
look,
it's easy to say they don't know me,
Ha,
I'm a tough guy,
Yada Yada.
But the reality is what they underestimated was the size of our audience.
I knew that I could go online,
which I never left.
I did the online show while I was at Msac for were like,
well,
you already got on TV,
what do you still bothering with online things?
But I'm like,
no,
no.
You schmucks the real deals online.
So I had the luxury of being able to go back to this giant audience online and
telling them to fuck off.
That's beautiful.
And explaining your story.
Yeah,
you see that's exactly it.
You nailed it again because part of the reason they get double your salary is so
you shut up.
Okay.
So they say,
oh progressive's,
what are you talking about?
I got this fire breather,
Janky Yoga from the young Turks on on the weekends.
He's part of our staple.
Ask them,
ask them and then you have to come out and be like,
yes,
MSNBC is very good.
They like progressing and you're thinking about your boat and you think about
your vacation house and you're thinking about your vacations.
You're thinking of all this shit that that money provides you.
Yeah.
Oh,
then I got young kids and,
and look,
if you didn't have the luxury that I had,
think about if you're in one in one of the other hosts position,
there is no fall back.
The fallback is a cliff.
You either going to get paid really well going to be a star.
They treat you so well when you're there.
Car Rides everywhere,
first class,
everywhere,
etc. Or You faced the abyss.
Nothing.
And Yeah,
you were almost,
you become an hireable.
That's right.
If you don't work well with MSNBC,
why would CNBC pick you up?
Why would this network or that network pick you up?
They wouldn't.
The word goes out in the street.
He doesn't play ball.
D a Oberman thing was an interesting thing cause I don't,
I don't know.
Keith Olbermann I've,
I've heard is difficult,
you know,
in a lot of ways.
But it's fascinating to see him go from being this fireball,
anti government crusader,
this sort of like,
I mean he kind of in a,
in a classic sense,
sort of an Edward r Murrow character and then now he's talking about baseball.
It's weird.
Like I watched him on ESPN and I'm waiting for like these fiery political
statements,
these,
uh,
these big strong monologues that he used to cry.
I mean,
they were very long winded.
The monologues could have done with some editing for sure.
Right?
I mean,
some of there was so verbose and obvious and they reeked of ego because it
wasn't just a statement.
It was him trying to make a statement in an eloquent way that would be
impressive.
Like it smelled like that.
Like you picked it.
I'd be like,
I don't think this is good.
You know,
like I get,
I'm with them,
I'm on a lot of shit,
but as Donald like it,
I don't like your monologues.
They just as two d they're too long.
There's too,
there's too much funkiness in him.
So Obama,
oh,
per month over month.
So that's like the Ubermensch.
Yeah.
Um,
he's a complicated character.
Lots of upsides and lots of downsides.
And so,
um,
the upside to what you're discussing,
other commentaries that he did was that he changed the face of television before
that it was all conservative.
Okay.
And he did it despite MSNBC,
say under penalty of law,
do not do that special comment on the show and overcoming being crazy.
That was the upside of crazy.
He's like,
hmm,
that's Kinda your opinion,
man.
Right.
My opinion is I'm going to go do this commentary.
And when it worked and it got such great ratings,
then management got behind him and pretended to be on his side the whole time.
Like Yelp,
of course.
Special comments.
Sure.
And they realized that there was a racket to be had and team Democrat,
right.
But at least Oberman even the score,
it was like,
okay,
now he had MSNBC doing democratic talking points and I'm not taking anything
away from open up over him and I think he's principled on his politics.
Uh,
and then you had to re Foxton who's doing it.
So that was a huge breakthrough.
So he's kind of a historic figure in that sense.
Um,
on the other hand,
he's crazy.
Like,
just crazy.
Like in what way?
Okay.
Folks,
not listening,
genx eyebrow,
but way up.
His eyes got very lucky.
And so that's why they put into was ESPN contract and he's not allowed to talk
about politics.
Right?
That's why he's,
and he loves sports.
That's genuine,
right?
So he's just doing sports and he's look a great example.
It was actually Bandfield back when,
uh,
MSNBC was conservative before the Obermann special comments and stuff around the
rack war.
Right,
exactly.
As the Iraq war was happening,
she did this speech at a college in Kansas and said,
this is crazy.
The Iraq war is,
we shouldn't do this.
And explain why.
Really eloquent,
really smart.
MSNBC said,
yeah,
you're off there.
Okay.
And they literally moved her into a closet.
And so,
uh,
they see we're not going to let you out of your contract.
You're not allowed to say that.
And they moved her office and do a closet that sent a message to everybody.
Shut up.
Okay.
And so if you don't play team ball,
ah,
that's the fate that way too.
And so,
okay.
Keith has kind of been banished into the closet of sports.
Like it's a closet we like,
I like sports,
he likes sports,
but they're not going to let him out again
to talk about politics.
Why does it need go on the online,
right?
Probably too old school.
It's hard for them to figure it out.
I mean,
look man,
you're going to go online like you do a,
we do.
You gotta be hungry,
right?
You gotta be ready to roll up your sleeves and take a lot of shit and get
battered and then get back up and stuff.
Those old school guys who've made a conciliation dollars,
they don't have it in him.
That's interesting.
That's an interesting comment.
Um,
yeah,
I you,
you definitely can get too used to that whole system of everything being set up
for you.
Like I have a buddy who does a podcast and he does a podcast on a network and
the network is owned by a major television network and they were censoring his
podcast and I was like,
what the fuck are you doing man?
This is a podcast.
The last thing you want is someone telling you what you can and can't say and
taking the bad words out of your mouth on the fucking Internet.
Are you crazy?
Or you're ruining everything that's great about the Internet and doing it this
way.
Yeah.
But he was like,
why do I do it?
Outside of that,
I'm like,
oh,
come on man,
you fucking get a microphone.
You plug it into an MP,
three recorder and you start talking and then you take that and then you throw
it online.
It's that simple.
And if it grows,
it grows.
You throw seeds out the window.
Some of them won't become trees,
you know,
it just fucking do it.
Just do it.
Uh,
too much work.
Too much thinking too outside the box.
Plus a guy like Keith who's been on TV for,
so I keep calling him Keith,
like I,
we're friends,
but we're not,
I mean,
so do you know him?
Have you had conversations with him?
I've had a couple conversations with them on a one to 10.
Wackiness
10.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Strong.
Um,
now I want him as a guest.
I wouldn't bring him on.
Is He allowed to do interviews where he talks about politics,
where he talks about things?
I would be shocked,
but I dunno.
I bet he's not right.
I bet they'd fucking trapped him.
Plus I bet he doesn't do it.
So like if you are on TV,
Rachel Maddow gave me a great speech before I ever got on TV.
A warning me about TV.
Okay.
Because we used to work together to America and then she was really helpful and
stuff at Msnbc and she's like,
just,
it'll get into your head.
Don't let it get into your head,
man,
because you take one too many limo rides,
you'll have one too many people telling you how great you are,
and then you lose track of what reality is.
And so a guy like Overman,
who's been on TV for so long and so successful for so long,
he spins into an orbit where he thinks he can't do anything wrong.
And then like the ego becomes so gigantic that it can't be punctured.
So if he were to go online,
it would get punctured.
Right.
You know,
you like,
there's a lot of compliments online,
but there's a lot of criticism,
right,
and an ego that large cannot handle that.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think that I find great benefit in that criticism.
I mean,
I know that some of it is completely unfounded and some of it is just a hundred
percent douche bags that are just assholes.
And you go to their Twitter page and you'll see just them just shitting on one
person after another.
Just random people that they don't know.
Celebrities,
common ners people on that have blogs,
whatever,
and just,
just hate,
hate,
hate.
Hate,
hate this.
There's folks like that.
There's also folks that will say something that you don't want to hear,
but you should hear it.
And you take that into consideration and it'll make you better.
It really well.
And there's the Obor mens are the people that don't want to engage in that.
Your,
yeah,
your ego's going to take a beating,
but your fucking ego should take a beating you.
He goes a dangerous thing.
And if it grows too much,
it can,
it can create a canopy that doesn't let all the other things grow underneath it.
That's 100%.
Right.
So,
uh,
some people hate the comments section on Youtube.
I don't,
I love it.
I mean,
I know there's mental people on there and if you listen to every comment,
you're gonna lose your mind.
Don't do that.
Right?
But overall,
if most people,
if 80% of the is agreeing to something,
it's almost certainly correct.
So if,
if they tell you,
hey,
you're going in this wrong direction,
well,
I take note of that man.
And I just,
if you don't adjust,
they're trying to help you.
You know what they are,
they're in the new media,
they're your editor right there,
your editor saying,
Hey,
don't do that.
You look like an asshole.
Do this.
Okay.
And if 80% of them agree on something,
I've never seen it be wrong.
And sometimes there's a,
there's a thing that you're doing when you're discussing an issue.
Uh,
we're,
we're where someone might have a criticism on it and it's one of the things that
I like about doing this show is it,
this show is three hours long and one of the things in having a three hour
conversation is that you get to really thoroughly discuss a point because you
could take snippets out of a lot of things.
Like there was a thing they did on real sports the other day about a Fallon Fox,
you know,
Fallon Fox is,
she's a woman who used to be a man who decided to get a sex change and then
fight and women's MMA.
And I,
me as a martial arts expert,
I was like,
I do not agree with that at all because there's certain undeniable advantages of
the human frame,
of the male frame and when it comes to combat sports,
when it comes to being a woman or being transgender,
I'm 100% supportive it.
I've used to be able to do whatever you want,
man.
If you want to marry your desk,
I'm,
I'm for it.
If you want to live with cats in the woods,
I don't give a fuck.
It just don't hurt anybody.
I couldn't care less and if you decide that you identify as a woman,
you want to be a woman,
I'm 100% in support of that.
I couldn't imagine what it's like to be that person and have these feelings and
to have them rejected by society.
I'm fully in sympathy and support of it.
Real sports.
He uses one like five second thing of me saying,
first of all,
it's not a woman.
It's not.
She has a y chromosome.
I mean,
I'll,
I'll call her a woman,
but you,
when science finds her body a thousand years from now,
they're going to go,
oh,
that was a man.
You know,
and when it comes to combat sports,
when it comes to,
when it comes to social interaction,
when it comes to culture,
when it comes to how you treat people,
I'm fully in support of transgenders,
but as a person who was a professional mixed martial arts commentator and who's
lived my entire life training in martial arts,
I'm very aware of the distinct advantages of the male frame.
That's just,
it's just that simple.
There's a reason why we don't let men fight women.
And when you didn't disclose the fact that she used to be a man anyway,
real sports takes five seconds of that and throws it out there.
That's the difference between a podcast and a television show and it television
show.
That five seconds becomes a three hour discussion where you go over all the
aspects of the emotional,
the damage that you must get.
Being a child,
wanting to be a woman and being a man and all the different realities of what
makes you a person and whether it's a learned experience or whether it's
genetics or all these devices,
subtle variations and trying to put yourself into that mindset.
There's so much to be said on so many different subjects,
but when you're on a fucking television show,
you don't get a chance when you're dealing with those seven minute things on red
eye on Fox,
and it's like,
and what's your take on global warming?
Real,
not real.
Jank you know,
and you're like,
well,
the,
the statistics say,
who's making this statistics?
We'll be right back with commercials like you,
fuck you're not,
you're not getting,
you're not getting to talk about things enough.
There's,
there's too much information.
There's too many subtle variations in thought that need to be sort of explored
when you,
when you delve into any sort of subject.
And I think that when we're talking about this whole right left paradigm and
this whole team Democrat thing that you faced when you were on MSNBC or the the
team Republican that Sean Hannity is a part of,
that sort of embodies the whole problem with television that really doesn't
exist in the same form on the Internet.
You're going to have people that agree and disagree in the Internet,
but in,
in a format like this,
you get to really cover a subject and really sort of let down your guard and
explore all the variables that TV doesn't let you do.
Look,
I miss our radio show so much because me Ben and chill pike at the time,
we'd come in and we do a three hour show and we just have the time of our lives.
We can do that.
No,
well it's because every format is different,
right?
And so our show is built for being online video.
So I got to squeeze it,
squeeze in as many topics as I can into the two hours that we do.
Uh,
so we can clip them up and put them up on Youtube.
Okay.
But I can't,
but I'm not going to do,
I'm going to do them justice.
Right?
So I'm going to take as long as I need,
but not a second more.
So I've done like 17 minute explanations of a topic cause it needed 17 minutes.
Right.
It might be the NSA wiretapping whatever.
But I needed to explain that and I explained it so I'm not rushing through
anything.
But at the same time,
I can't have a conversation like this because this is great for a podcast.
That's why your podcast as well and it does great.
Um,
but if you put this up on Youtube,
people are gonna be like,
wow,
three hours.
Well we do put it on Youtube.
Well,
I hear you.
We just started recently.
Like wait a year ago.
Yeah,
about a year ago.
Yeah.
So it's just a different format and I've done all those different formats,
but I miss the radio days.
Like we'd walk in in a t shirt,
like you didn't have to worry about your forehead.
You're 90 you're shining the powder you up for the young Turks.
I on myself
in the beginning.
I remember when I was in Miami,
I always thought the signal for success was if you got makeup,
you knew you made it if you were getting makeup.
Okay.
That's great.
Yeah.
And then,
but then when I was on TV,
I hated makeup because I,
it felt,
it felt like it was a symbol of the fakeness of television to cake it on you and
then you feel like one of these like Shepard Smith.
Yeah.
You,
if you feel like you're in the capitol,
you know,
in hunger games,
like,
you know,
they've put on this makeup and you go out there and you entertain the masses,
whatever.
I Dunno.
I,
so now I just put on my own,
I figured out,
is this a hilarious conversation but what foundation works best for me?
And so like five minutes before the show,
I'll,
I'll go in the uh,
in the bathroom and I'll put it on and it's not caked on it just so that my
forehead doesn't shine.
Yeah.
I signed like a motherfucker,
but I do also during the,
the UFC they tried to,
well they don't now,
but they tried in the early days to powder me up.
You know the,
the other guys that I work with get powdered up.
They put the makeup on you.
I'm like behind me,
I'm going to get,
people are going to get kicked in the fucking face.
Their head's going to swell up like the elephant man.
And you're worried if my skin is shiny,
there's no way I'm letting you touch me with that shit.
We're going to fight.
You try to fucking powder me up.
We're going to have a real problem because this is ridiculous.
This is what I look like.
All this shit.
If I have a Zit,
I have a Zit.
So what I look like,
my problem is that if you don't put at least something to take the shine off,
it looks like I'm sweating like a maniac.
I'm not,
but it looks like,
right,
right.
One skin.
You're,
you're oily.
Yeah,
I'm Mediterranean,
so I,
yeah.
So I once I was super late for an interview,
I was going to do with some guy who was the rhino hunter or whatever,
and I jumped in the seat.
I didn't do the foundation.
And he's conservative and he's a hunter.
Right?
Is this the guy who won that?
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
The guy that was going to kill David and Ryan killed it.
Whoa.
Right.
So then I come out of the interview and people were like,
Oh yeah,
I see that guy eat like I scared you.
Right.
That's why you were sweating like that.
Oh
yeah.
I'm like,
first of all,
we agreed on like 90% of stuff.
I don't know what you're talking about,
but that's the perception that people get.
So that's why I don't want to seem like I'm sweating like a maniac.
That's so funny.
They want that perception.
They want that.
They look for that.
They look,
oh,
he was scared he was skating with every form that opinion before we even sat
down to talk to them.
Yeah.
I was scared of what the guy's going to come hunt me down from Texas.
Like,
you know,
agree with that guys hunting the whole country.
Then if that's the case,
I mean he's got a hunt 100 million people that are angry at him for wanting to
shoot that rhino.
Yeah.
That Rhino story was a very fascinating story because if you,
if you talk to the conservation people that say,
well at Rhino had to be removed from the herd anyway because it was a larger
older male and it was trying to kill the young males because it didn't want them
breeding and it's actually dangerous for the population of the rhinos.
Like many things,
that whole,
uh,
African hunting thing is a very confusing and complex issue.
Yep.
He made a really good case for it on the show.
Well,
we were talking about it with Louis Theroux.
He,
uh,
you know,
Louis through the documentarian from England,
fascinating guy,
and he's done some amazing documentaries and one of his best ones was on these
African hunts and in Africa,
these wild animals that used to be on the verge of extinction are now like in
the greatest populations we've seen in years.
Like they're really healthy populations,
but they're all in these high fence hunting areas,
so their,
their populations are great,
but people get to pay to kill him.
So I was like,
Whoa,
that a fucking,
that is humanity in a nutshell right there.
That's society,
culture and an I just up fucking the weird contradictory nature of the whole
thing where it's not very black and white.
There's a lot of weirdness going on there.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Like I think we get carried away with the conservation mentality.
Here's what I mean by that.
Of course we need conservation,
but like then they'll be like,
okay,
well that rhino is an older rhino so he will attack the younger rhinos so it's
actually better to kill him.
So he doesn't do that.
But I'm like,
wait a minute.
If we're trying to preserve how they actually live,
that's what older rhinos do.
They in fact the younger rhinos,
yes.
They didn't make that up.
That's in their DNA.
The problem is,
is not enough rhino support that the,
the issue becomes when you,
you have a large quantity of it,
a large quantity of rhinos,
that's fine.
That's natural.
It's normal,
right?
But when you have a small herd that could really do some serious damage,
So that's why it's so complicated.
Like how then,
how do you resolve that?
Do you let people kill him?
But if you do though,
your whole point was conservation,
why are you letting people execute them?
You know?
But on the other hand in it,
if you don't,
then maybe you cost yourself three younger rhinos.
And that's a real problem.
So the problem is that is humans,
right?
We've taken over everything.
We're the virus,
right?
Yeah.
And so since we've taken over everything,
we've got these,
all these little things in artificial cages,
it might be a small cage in a zoo,
or it might be a large cage in one of those preserves in Africa.
But essence,
we've killed what quote unquote naturally happen.
Well,
we've become the stewards of the,
of nature itself.
And we've decided that,
I mean,
after this point that I've been talking about a lot lately about zoos,
about how terrible it is for the genetics of all these animals,
for them to be isolated.
The idea is that you're preserving these animals.
You can come see in them,
oh,
we've let these pandas breed that.
Well,
you know,
here's the reality.
Pan Is they're supposed to breathe if they can,
if they don't get eaten by tigers because you're supposed to be tigers around
the pan is or whatever the fuck their natural Predator is.
It's supposed to be jaguars around the monkeys and they're supposed to be lions
around the,
the,
the giraffes.
I mean that's just what happens in nature and when we have them all segregated
in these apartments and you know,
we've slide food under the tray and the tray underneath the door.
Like why the fuck are we doing here?
Like we're,
we're anti nature here.
This is everything against,
I mean these things are surviving period.
No matter what they're surviving.
We're not trying to preserve nature.
We're trying to preserve at time frozen.
Hmm.
You know,
like nature frozen in time at that time,
right?
This is what we're used to.
We liked the drafts like this.
We like the pandas like that and we'd like to preserve it.
But in reality,
nature is not in the conservation business.
No,
it's in the struggle business.
Right.
And so oftentimes things will go extinct because that's what happened.
Cause the tigers ate all the pandas Saturday.
And what'll happen is the panda will then breed with a Koala or whatever.
I mean to speak incredibly ignorantly and then you'll get a new species.
Right?
But that's what's awesome about nature because like you don't know what's going
to happen.
There'll be destruction,
there'll be creation,
but we have short circuited that.
So there is no good answer.
Right?
The answer isn't a fuck them.
Let them all die.
That's not the answer.
And the answer isn't let's stop all progress in all creation right now.
Right.
And try to preserve it as it is today.
That's not the answer either.
So I don't know what the answer is.
Well,
the answer is also that human beings are a part of nature and that our nature is
to fuck with things.
And that is nature and it's a very strange thing for us to think about in that
way.
But all human behavior,
everything from computers to pollution to t to communication through cell
phones,
all that stuff is natural.
It's just natural with human beings.
And it's a,
it's a very strange,
just as natural as a macaw and making weird noises.
And that's natural too.
It just is natural for you to send a Dick pic through your fucking cell phone.
These are natural things.
It's just,
it's so complex and so outside of the norm for every other multi-celled species
on the planet that we don't like to think of it.
It's natural.
We look,
think of it as human created,
but everything human created is just as natural as a beehive,
just as natural as an ant hill.
Those are natural as well.
You know,
I never thought about it that way.
But you're right,
there's nothing more natural than a dick pic because,
no,
but like literally like,
you know,
Eh,
we have larger penises than other primates do because that's part of how we
attract women.
We swing our dicker rat.
So that's us swinging our dick around over the internet and saying,
Hey,
anybody interested?
And there's also a direct correlation between the,
the amount of promiscuous females and the size of the male penis.
So it's,
there's all these slutty women,
God damn problem.
That's why Dick pics exist.
It gets better.
So my,
so my favorite thing is just discussing the genetic reasons for the male anatomy
and female anatomy.
But the,
so our penis is designed both like a shovel and as a vacuum.
Okay.
And the reason for that is that there is intra-vaginal sperm competition.
So within the vagina you,
there is an expectation that several different men in the same rough time period
have ejaculated.
So our penis is designed to get our seamen n and the other guy's semen out.
So that's why our penis is designed like a shovel to shovel out the other guy's
semen and like a suction.
So it takes all of the semen that it finds in the vagina before it entered and
suctions it back out.
So if you think women are monogamous,
mm Rdna would tell you otherwise.
Yeah.
In small groups and not very monogamous at all.
That is an interesting thing that the head is designed in that way to plunge out
sort of as a plunger.
Right.
And the size of the testicles are in direct correlation to the amount of
promiscuity females that are around like the with,
with men and tribes that have larger testicles.
Usually the women are more promiscuous.
That's why chimpanzees have large testicles.
But gorillas,
small testicles and small penises.
Grills have a one inch penis.
Yup.
Tiny little penis.
It falls out all the time.
You're watched.
Grill is mate.
I have,
when you watch gorillas mate,
they uh,
they have a hard time keeping it in there.
There's not a lot of,
a lot of length to work with.
It's because they have complete total control over the females that are around
them.
They have a whole Harem.
Yeah.
Who needs a large penis.
When,
uh,
you know,
if you got any male competition,
just crushed her skull.
Yeah.
My friend Kevin has a little Dick and he's,
he always admits to it and uh,
he,
he jokes around about it goes,
hey man,
it feels good for me.
I don't care.
That's sort of how the girl feels.
Yeah.
So we have large balls and that means of course the males are also not
monogamous.
And so we live in this,
in our own little preserve where we are in monogamous relationships for a
lifetime,
which is clearly not natural.
And I had a,
um,
a guy who does porn on the show last week,
his name is Dave pounder and he wrote a book about his real name.
Oh,
of course not.
He said when he was getting into the porn business is two choices where Dave
pounder and Dave impaler,
any thought,
eh,
pounder is a little better than impaler.
Okay.
So,
uh,
he did a documentary and a book is a really smart guy.
Super Smart Guy and he said a guy who's in a longterm relationship that's
monogamous is like a gay guy in a closet.
Right?
The gay guys at Gay,
whether he admits it or he doesn't.
Right.
And in your monogamous relationship,
you're actually polygamous.
Whether he admitted or you don't,
you're just in the closet about it.
Right?
Cause there's nobody who's actually monogamous.
Do you see what I'm saying?
You can act monogamous,
but you're not monogamous in your mind.
You're not monogamous in your nature.
So when you don't admit that to your wife or your girlfriend,
you're just like a gay guy in the closet.
You don't admit what your true nature.
Right.
That's a very fascinating way of putting it.
There's a good friend of mine,
his doctor,
Chris Ryan,
he has a,
I'm going to call him doctor.
I call him Doc Chris Ryan.
I had him on the show sex at dawn.
We do a podcast together once a month.
It's awesome.
He a Duncan Trussell and myself,
we do this.
We come up with,
we don't have a name for it.
We call it the shrimp parade sometimes.
Sometimes it's called the old men and snow because that's what Chris used to
think about,
to keep himself from orgasming.
He's thinking about old eastern bloc men walking painfully in the snow and that
would keep him from having an orgasm.
Always having sex.
Okay.
I'm now going to tell you something I've never told anybody and then I shouldn't
tell you.
Okay.
But I think that's partly the point of the Joe Rogan podcast.
So,
um,
I,
you got to come up with something,
right?
Yeah.
So I used to think about football,
but I'd get really conflicted.
I'd always think about the chargers,
right?
Cause I really liked the charge back then,
but then I'm thinking about dudes and then I was like,
and I'm like,
I gotta get this Outta my head.
Okay.
But it worked because then I wouldn't come.
So as partly how you know you're straight with,
it's also like is a fine line.
You don't want to think it's about something too fucked up.
We start to lose your bone and then you're like,
oh no,
exactly.
So you've got all these crazy things going on in your head.
But yes.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
uh,
Chris Ryan had this conversation where it was,
we were on the podcast,
he was talking to someone.
It was,
someone was saying,
well,
look,
I'm monogamous.
And the guy was like,
okay,
we're,
Chris was like,
you're okay.
Your mom goes,
do you jerk off to porn?
And the guy said,
yes.
He goes,
well then you're not monogamous unless you're jerking off to porn,
only have your wife.
You're not monogamous.
You're just,
you're just monogamous in your actions.
Your mind,
you have your fantasies are of these other women,
you know?
And that's undeniable.
It's human nature.
It's just,
it's a part being a primate,
even if it's not your wife.
Does anybody jerk off to this same picture or video in porn to the same woman
every time there's gotta be a guy?
I mean,
I,
yeah,
there's probably like one or a couple of guys,
but I kind of feel bad for him.
Dude.
It's a fantasy.
Go nuts.
3 billion women out there as part of having an imagination,
but
explore it.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a very fascinating topic because,
uh,
you know,
with Chris Ryan's book,
sex at dawn,
he goes into the,
what sort of explores what started out as these tribes of small people,
you know,
or small groups of 5,150 people that are all living together and you know,
exchanging sexual partners.
And it was very commonplace.
And as agriculture gets established and as these populations grow larger and
larger,
it becomes weirder and weirder.
And then it stops.
And then we start realizing that our sperm creates that kid.
And that kid is my kid and I don't want anybody else near my wife who made my
kid.
And then mail paternity line gets established.
And then,
you know,
the dominance of the breed and really real weird,
weird stuff with human beings when it comes to sexuality and monogamy.
But,
but fascinating too.
And again,
it's,
you know,
it's more,
more evidence as to how contradictory are our nature is and how strange.
Yeah.
Being humans trippy.
I mean like where'd these animals,
right?
That's where we are.
We're animals and we have a certain programming,
you know,
we'd sell our DNA is like we're a computer with a program,
but we're also like animals.
Like we wanna fuck.
We want to sometimes rip somebody's head off and we have all these urges and we
have these passions,
but yet we're conscious of it all so we can step back and see the animal that we
are and the robot that we are.
And that's really mind bending.
Yeah,
it is mind bending because it's unique to the,
the,
the actual life on this planet.
There's only one at all the animals and the planet.
There might be other animals that are conscious like dolphins and Orca as they
might communicate with each other.
They might have family groups and dialects and all that,
but they don't alter their environment the way we do.
So we're conscious,
we're aware,
we communicate,
we alter our environment and we keep records.
You know,
I don't know how much dolphins know about their great,
great,
great grandfathers,
but we know a Shitload,
you know,
and we will quote [inaudible] or we'll,
we'll,
we'll talk about homer and you know,
we'll discuss people that lived a thousand years ago as if,
you know,
we know exactly what they were like.
And that is very uniquely human.
So we sorta chart how retarded we used to be in comparison to how retarded we
currently are and see this progress.
Yeah.
And our nature is oftentimes very much at war with itself.
Uh,
and it's a hell of a balanced the pull off.
So yes,
we're polygamists,
there's no question about that.
The flip side of that is then why does almost every celebrity,
and finally we lost George Clooney.
So I can now I think saying every celebrity still get married because if we were
just polygamous,
you'd be crazy to get married.
If you're a celebrity,
if you're a guy,
right?
You get a hundred girls,
you get a thousand girls,
why would you get stay?
Because there's also a part of our nature that wants to nest.
And that once have a one on one relationship.
So good luck trying to balance that out.
And that's what we struggle with through our whole lives.
And then you've got our competitive nature and our nature where we cooperate.
Right?
And everybody makes a mistake of going on one side or another.
Like there'll be a group that thinks no,
people are competitive.
They want to,
you know,
and you're crazy if you're thinking that they were ever going to cooperate.
And then there's the guys who were like,
Hey,
no,
people hold their hands together and sing Kumbaya.
And normally they'd be no war and all that stuff.
No.
Well that's no,
neither side is true.
No,
we're sometimes incredibly competitive and want to rip each other's heads off.
And sometimes we're incredibly cooperative and we worked together to create
great things.
It's a balance.
So look,
in a lot of ways it's awesome because if the world was black and white,
it'd be too easy.
Yeah,
I agree 100% and I think that that conflict is sort of what fuels thinking and
what few,
I think that's the Yin and Yang of life.
You,
you almost need conflict to try to sort of motivate you to work things out and
motivate you to improve,
motivate you to evolve and change and to grow and to take into consideration all
these different facets of,
of,
of life itself.
And I think that we all want everything to be this perfect,
you know,
golden age of,
of you know,
love and sharing and compassion.
But in order to really truly appreciate that,
you kind of have to have some shit around to,
to compare it to some just like people that grow up rich,
they'll never understand how beautiful it is to have enough money to not worry
about money,
but so true.
Yeah.
It's like if you grow up in a family where you,
everyone's being driven around in limousines and there's money everywhere and
you have servants and it's got to be incredibly difficult to understand the true
struggle.
Whereas if you grow up like you are like,
I don't know,
you know what your childhood was like,
but my childhood,
very poor.
I appreciate every dollar I have.
I appreciate the freedom that it gives me in that I don't have to worry about
money because that weight of constantly worrying about your bills is one of the
worst things that people have.
I cut a lot of people,
a lot of slack that do fucked up things for money that are broke because I
remember what it was like to feel that weight.
Like,
God,
I don't know how I'm gonna pay my bills this month.
I don't know what's next month's going to be.
What if I get sick?
I don't have health insurance.
I kind of foreign health insurance.
What if this happens?
What if that happens?
How do I take care of that?
How am I ever going to stop?
Where's my glow?
Golden years is going to come from,
where's the retirement?
There's no fucking retirement for a lot of people.
It's a joke.
This idea that you're going to get to one point,
we're going to settle down and everything's going to be great.
You know,
work hard to the end of the day and the end of the day it's Miller time and they
look at life like there's a Miller time for life.
There's no fucking Miller time,
man.
It's not happening.
You're going to get to a certain point and then you're going to go now what?
And then your heart's going to stop.
Yeah.
Uh,
so is a million things to say about it,
but first you should,
you should coin that.
There is no fucking Miller time.
No Miller time for life.
Um,
I remember when I was a struggling talk show host on the radio and I remember
looking at a Snapple for like five straight minutes,
but I mean like literally five minutes and it was a dollar.
And I'm like,
I could just have water with my breakfast.
I don't need that Snapple.
But God,
I really want that Snapple.
And I,
and I always remember that like a dollar meant extra enjoyment that day for me
and I,
so I value it.
But,
so that leads to a ironic conclusion.
I actually feel bad for people who grew up rich like this.
Kind of a funny thing to say.
Um,
like Russell Simmons is always talking about,
oh,
you should meditate and don't worry about money.
I'm like,
yeah,
Russell,
but you got $300 million.
Right?
It's easy to say,
don't worry about money when you have $300 million.
Right?
Yeah.
It's harder for a person who trying to pay the rent and figuring out where
they're going to get food for their kids and stuff like that,
and I know that,
I know that feeling of like being super stressed out about not having money and
the effects of that,
but when you get a little bit,
it feels a thousand times better because if you grew up rich,
you just,
you,
it's not your fault.
You just take it for granted.
There's because you never had any other contexts like you don't know.
You have no idea how phenomenal it is to fly first class or business class or to
get driven around in limos.
You like,
you take it as well,
that's normal.
So you can only go down if you lose that stuff.
Oh,
then you're like,
oh my God,
my world has exploded.
How can anyone live like this?
Right?
But you,
it's hard to go up and it's hard to have that context.
So look,
I think I'm the lucky sky a lot because I grew up middle class,
so I had enough that I can get an education and I didn't have to,
you know,
sell drugs.
I didn't have to do any crazy shit to get money.
Right.
So my dad provided that for me,
but I grew up middle class enough that I value money and I,
you know,
and it means the world's like anybody who says that money is an important,
doesn't know what they're talking about,
hasn't been poor enough to understand that yes,
money's fucking important.
Bored.
I totally agree with you about being unfortunate.
If you grow up rich,
I really do.
I think that,
uh,
especially if you grow up rich with ignorant parents and parents that don't sort
of explain to you in great detail how fortunate you are to be in the situation
and the importance of appreciating the struggle.
But I have this weird relationship with money and uh,
it's gotten weirder and weirder over the last few years where it's going to
sound really crazy and it sounds crazy even to me,
but I,
I objectively look at humans and I look at what we're doing and I look at this
sort of system that we set up and we think it's just this is the way people
operate you,
you exchanged money for goods and this is,
our society is based on money and it's all about trying to earn money.
But I look at it and I go,
well,
that's just a creation.
That's just a man made creation.
And what else is going on?
Well,
what else is going on is there's this slow but inevitable
sort of dissolving of the boundaries between human beings and information and
whether that information is the secrets about the NSA or that information is,
you know,
things that are on the internet,
emails,
photographs.
There's the,
the trend is to have a ultimate access to all information for everyone and I
think that we're going to come to a bottleneck and the bottleneck is going to be
that.
What is money exactly?
Well,
at this point in time it's,
it's just ones and Zeros.
It's just information.
Money now is broken down to when I'm a gold standard anymore.
Our monies based entirely on information.
It's information in a database somewhere.
Well,
there's going to be a point in time where we have to decide as a civilization
that the only way to continue to move forward with our innovation to can you
continue to move forward with technology.
We're going to have to dissolve the boundary between human beings and the
information that is money.
The money's not going to be worth anything anymore.
It's going to be a weird,
we're going to have to come up with some new way in order to transfer wealth or
to determine wealth or to determine reward for effort or you know,
whatever you're doing.
Because if,
if we're just basing it on what we're basing it on now,
it's inevitable that it comes to this point where you're not going to be able to
protect your money.
You're not going to be able to,
it's not going to be able to store it.
You're not going to build,
it's not going to it.
It's not going to be anywhere.
And if it's just ones and Zeros,
everyone's going to have access to it.
It's getting the distribution of it is going to get very weird.
So I'm trying to understand that.
So is the main problem there you think if you follow that to it's natural
conclusion that it's going to get hacked?
No,
I don't even think it's going to be,
I think we're calling it hacked now,
but I think the trend seems to be too,
no secrets,
no secrets.
Complete transparency.
I think the ultimate hive mind state you that is talked about in sort of eastern
mysticism that we are all one.
I think we are all one and I think we're going to achieve that through
technology and I think that's something that no one saw coming.
I think that the,
the hive mind is going to come through something that the,
this cellular mine events and then there's going to be some sort of a connection
between all the people all the time and we experienced it that we're
experiencing that now by being able to access the database of human knowledge on
your cell phone to be able to ask Siri what the answer to a question is.
You know,
use as Google and boom,
you get answers.
I mean that's unprecedented in human history,
but that to me is just like,
that's like one of those old school he photographs so they have to throw the
cape over and everybody stands still for a minute and poof.
They press that button and the thing flashes and everybody has to stand still
and then you get this weird black and white image,
which was magic in 1850 or whenever the fuck the camera was invented.
I think that that's this step that you've gotten to now where I have thousands
of photos on my phone,
thousands and I take them instantly.
I could press a button and goes,
come on,
and they'll take a a series of pictures in a row.
That's,
that's madness in comparison.
That big stupid Cape.
Well,
I think that the access to information that we enjoy today by being able to
Google search something but need being able to go to your phone and find the
information,
it's going to get closer than that.
It's going to be something where it's a chip that you put in your,
in your,
in your body and it interfaces with your mind.
It's going to be,
there's going to be something,
whether it's nanotechnology,
whatever it is,
they're going to continue to innovate.
They're going to continue to expand on technology.
And the trend is that there is no boundary at one point,
at the zero point,
there's going to be no boundary between human beings and information and money's
just information.
It's all it is.
It's an information on a database somewhere and you're going to,
there's going to be a bottleneck.
Well,
we,
we have to decide how we manage that database,
how we manage the access to that information.
Because if,
if the ultimate trend of this technology is to erode all these boundaries and
to,
to have us all communicating in sync,
you're not going to be able to have anything restricted.
You're not going to have anything that is outside of the access of everyone.
And money is that thing.
So we're going to come to a point in time where we're going to have to evolve as
a culture,
as a race,
as a species.
And part of that evolution is to restructure ideas of wealth,
restructure our ideals of the distribution of wealth.
What it means to have wealth.
This might,
well,
we're in talking about now,
I grew up poor,
you know,
you grew up middle class and then now I appreciate money and you appreciate
money.
That ain't going to even be an issue a thousand years from now because it will
have been dissolved by technology,
first of all.
Fascinating.
And,
uh,
and
I like,
I like your vision of like,
I dunno if you're kneel there in melting the matrix,
Jay.
But,
um,
it,
it's,
um,
so money is a,
is a tool,
right?
And so in your ultimate vision,
I don't know how that tool is then applied.
So in our current society,
we make this huge mistake of thinking that it's the end,
but it's not the end goal.
It's only a tool.
If you think it's end goal,
you're gonna make yourself miserable,
right?
Cause then there's never enough of it.
And the point of the money was to make you're happy.
But if you've replaced happiness with the end goal of money,
there's no winning that fight.
Right?
So it would be really interesting to see how
that paradigm would be in your transit,
dental world.
So,
and,
and there's this great fascinating circle there because everybody being one is
something that I largely believe in as well.
Um,
and it's what almost everybody that thinks it through once they get past
religion gets too.
So whether it's the Taoists you know,
that you're referring to in eastern philosophy,
it's a transcendentalist here in the u s the Ralph Waldo Emerson,
Henry David Thoreau's.
Um,
it's the Sioux fees in a,
in Muslim tradition,
they all come to the same conclusion.
We're all one,
it's not necessarily a god above us.
It's that we're all United in some way that's,
we can't tell them the physical space that we're in.
Right.
And the physical space that we're in,
we all seem divided.
Like you're right there and I'm right here.
But if you break it down,
you know,
on a cellular level,
you realize that that's actually not necessarily the case because everything is
not stable.
It,
it revolves.
And so the difference between the air and my hand is not nearly as distinct as
we think it is.
Right?
But what would be interesting is if the oldest,
you know,
philosophy,
we have the Dallas philosophy of everyone being one and United at some point met
with the future where everything is United in it's Zeros and ones and zeroes,
non-existence and one is existence.
And we are all one right in the,
in the vision that you have.
And I think that you might be right that we,
but that's really hard for our minds to grasp.
Like then what happens?
The money,
what happens to individuals,
what happens to all those things that are so important to us now?
And how is that part of our nature now?
But it's not necessarily part of our eternal nature.
So those answers,
I don't know.
I think that everything works to ultimately become more and more complex.
Um,
our society becomes more and more complex.
Our technology becomes more and more complex.
Our language or understanding of each other becomes more and more complex.
And when I look at what human beings used to be and what we are now,
and then I just just take myself out of the situation that I've become so
accustomed to,
you know,
modern life in 2014 with the language being noises that come out of your mouth
and typing on a keyboard and I sort of extrapolate like,
what,
where's this gonna go?
Were where is it ultimately going to go?
That's where I came up with this idea of the money bottleneck because I really
think that money is ultimately just that it's just information and our idea that
we have to exchange money and the way that we do now in order to stay alive.
But that's not true because there was times and there's cultures right now where
they don't have money.
They have a barter system.
You know,
there's people that you ever watch that show life a life below zero.
Nope.
It's a show on,
um,
God,
I want to say discovery channel.
Um,
but it's a,
these people living in Alaska,
they all live above the arctic circle.
And um,
a great deal of them don't use money.
They just barter,
they give each other a Caribou and this guy has a belt for your snowmobile.
And then they exchange like this and quite fascinating and very,
very friendly,
happy,
healthy people,
at least how they're portrayed on the show.
And it gives you this kind of,
this thought process of like,
well,
what is money?
You know,
what,
what is money to these,
these people that they don't really buy things.
They,
everything they get is from fishing or from hunting.
And then using that fit you like,
I'll give you this,
you give me that.
I am,
but I might disagree with you on this one because to me that sounds miserable.
Well like I want to go grab a burger,
right?
Fried Friday.
And so,
so look in small communities that can work.
And of course that's the essence of monies.
Border trade.
I do this,
I do like,
I do a talk show and I get paid a certain amount of money for that.
And then I exchange it for burgers and rent and all that stuff.
Right?
So I think money is a good tool as long as you realize what it is.
It's just makes things more efficient in a larger society.
So I don't want to go back to living like Eskimos,
nor do I.
But I think the,
when I'm looking at the complexity,
I view these people that are living in this sort of a barter situation as a step
along the way.
And money simplified the entire process of exchanging goods.
And it simplified everything.
Well,
let's just agree upon coins that equal this and we'll have a bank of these
things.
But then somewhere along the line that bank became a fucking hard drive
somewhere and that gold is like,
where's Fort Knox?
Is it even fucking exist anymore?
What's in there?
It was under wt seven fucking open up a door and you see this empty room,
like dust on the ground.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Where's the gold?
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
it was under wt seven.
Right.
Okay.
And by the way,
I'm choking everybody calmed down.
He knows,
he knows things.
Okay.
I,
they think
that what,
what we have established today is,
is functional.
It works.
It's great.
In a certain sense,
it is good to be able to use a credit card and buy a,
if you need to television,
you don't want to have to fucking figure out,
you know,
how many trees you have to chop down in order to give a guy to get a television
back.
It's way simpler process.
But this is just a step along the way and this process,
it's not going to maintain,
it's not going to stay the way it is now.
It does.
This is not the way,
it wasn't the Roman days and it's not the way it was even a hundred years ago.
When we're on the gold standard,
it's going to change.
So,
okay.
On that note,
uh,
I've talked to like,
I dunno,
countless financial experts on the show because,
well,
there was part of the TV show or the online show.
I mean over the course of the last 12 years that I've been doing the young
Turks,
I've talked to guys who've written books about the Fed guys who were in the Fed.
Just everybody,
first of all,
let me just state,
no one knows what the Fed is,
right?
Like you get me the top financial expert on the Fed,
I will break them down in a matter of maximum six questions.
Okay,
so the point where he will say,
Oh yeah,
no,
I don't really know how that,
like they don't like no one knows.
They know as much as I do.
They know the,
okay,
all right,
this is what the Fed kind of roughly does,
but where's the money?
Who Prints it?
And then once it's printed,
why do they give it to the banks?
Why does it have to be given to the banks?
Why can't it be given to the American people?
Well,
who controls the Fed?
I mean,
look,
some of those things have simple answers,
but when you start going deeper down into that rabbit hole,
no like no one knows.
And it's really scary.
And by the way,
is almost in my mind,
it's indisputable that we will have a massive global meltdown,
a economic meltdown and indisputable.
Like I think,
I don't know if it's a year and a half from now,
I don't know.
Jesus.
Maybe they keep it together for 12 years,
15 years,
but at some point this whole thing will melt down because it's just one giant
pyramid scheme.
Yeah.
It's built on a foundation of unfixable bullshit.
That's how I describe it.
It's just,
yeah,
there's that plus the system.
It's like,
you know,
earlier we were talking about why do we have the politicians that we do?
Why do we have the media will do it?
It's all based on the system that you build.
Why do we have the humans that we do?
It's in our DNA.
It's,
that's what was programmed into us and we have programmed our politics to be
fucked up.
Uh,
we program politics to be,
politicians need money to get elected.
Uh,
so they will do the bidding of the people who give them money.
Now that's why do we build it that way?
That's ridiculous.
That's so stupid.
Then they're never going to represent you.
They're going to represent the people who give them the money.
Like we should fix the system.
That's what I want to do.
That's why I set up a super pac called the wolf pack to basically obliterate all
the other superpacs.
Right?
Because as long as there's money in politics,
we're fucked it.
They will never represent us.
That's not how the machine is built.
The machine is built to represent the donors.
95% of the time,
the person with more money wins.
Right.
Incorporations and this is what leads to the global economic meltdown.
As soon as a corporation is born,
it's Oedipus.
It wants to kill it's dad capitalism and fucking swamp democracy.
Okay.
And because he doesn't want the free market,
a corporation wants a monopoly,
it wants ultimate growth.
[inaudible] wants maximum expansion and wants to destroy everything in its path.
And I don't mean like in some like environmental way or they'll destroy things.
I mean,
no,
like destroy the competition so that there's no one left.
So they make money easier.
Right.
And okay,
I get that.
And I understand the need for corporations,
but you've got to write,
rewrite one line of code there.
You can't let public corporations,
uh,
run a muck the way that we have.
Here's,
here's what I mean,
just a little bit more specific.
If you're a public corporation in you're an executive at that public
corporation,
you have no,
you don't even care what happens to that corporation.
All you care about is your short term benefit as long as you're an executive in
that corporation.
So you will do what ever it takes to make short term money,
including especially if you're at a bank,
a public bank take as much risk as humanly possible,
cause more risk equals more short term reward.
That system is built to explode.
You will eventually take so much risk that the bank will collapse.
It happened in 2008 and they were barely able to piece it back together the next
time the day.
Want to do maximum risk,
maximum risk.
If you're a Gambler,
I'm a gambler.
If you gamble,
you know,
you take maximum risk for long enough.
It's a fact.
It's a certainty that you will lose all of your money.
That's what they're going to do.
Because there's a,
there's a wrong line of code in there where the executives of the public
corporations don't care about the public corporations.
They don't care about the American democracy and American people,
et Cetera.
And then we let them buy our politicians.
Yeah.
The representative democracy that we exist in right now too.
It's,
I don't,
I,
it's,
I think it's a terribly flawed system and I don't think you need to represent
people that can speak for themselves.
It seems to be that what we used to need and the w the way it used to be
established was back when communication was incredibly difficult.
It was,
you couldn't just vote online.
You couldn't just talk online.
You couldn't just,
you know,
answer questions or express your opinions on things.
But now you can.
And so to have this antiquated system representing us and then the fact that
this transparency that we're seeing evolve before our eyes change rapidly on a
day to day basis.
I mean there's new revelations that come,
like the NSA spying thing,
like within a year,
the whole world attitude about email and and and,
and transactions and doing things online completely changed within a year.
Everyone assumes that everything that you put online,
whether it's a,
an email you send to a friend,
whether it's a text message that you received from a lover,
all those things are public.
All those things,
if not public now very well may be public one day and at the very least are
accessible by the government who may or may not use that to intimidate and or
manipulate you.
So we've changed the way we think and then ultimately intimidate and or
manipulate them because just like technology,
when technology first enters into the human arena,
it becomes a tool of the wealthy and the privileged like cell phones.
It's what you go to the old rapper videos,
you see rappers with those giant,
big stupid brick cell phones.
They were letting you know that they are wealthy and privileged.
That's part of the whole rap culture.
But now you can go to South America and the jungle and you'll see someone with a
fucking iPhone.
I mean it,
it spreads,
and I think that that technology is the spreading of that technology.
It just indicative of this constant ripple effect of progress,
of,
of technological progress rather,
and that this is ultimately going to happen with transparency as well.
What the government has the ability to do now with this NSA spying spy,
this gent guy's got a fucking big mouth.
He likes to tell,
let's find out what he's doing.
Let's get into his email,
see if he's got some gay porn that we could blackmail him with or something.
Let's,
let's don't,
I definitely don't.
I don't know why you would say that because I don't,
I don't know why that came up because I definitely don't.
It's just an example.
You know,
let's,
let's dig into this guy's life and what we're going to be able to dig into their
lives too.
It's just right now we can't,
but we will be able to,
everyone will be able to dig in to everything everybody else has.
Okay.
Now that you,
you're going down that road.
I realize that and I just came upon this as you were talking,
cause this,
you were making a really interesting point.
It's not just that we can go into their lives,
it's like going into our lives is going to be a really valuable asset for them
for limited window.
Right.
Until we all realize how fucked up we all are.
Yes.
So they'll be able to go into it and say,
ha ha gay porn.
Ah Ha this.
And then eventually we're gonna be like,
wait a minute.
Everybody's how,
how this or how,
how that,
yes.
So then who gives a shit?
All right.
Fuck it.
Exactly.
I think that's a very important point.
And that,
you know,
uh,
Ana Kasparian had that exact same point.
We were on the podcast,
we were sorta talking about transparency.
We're,
we're saying that it a certain point in time we're going to,
everybody's got to look at everybody else's bullshit and it's not going to
matter anymore cause it's gonna it's gonna go away the same way.
You know,
during the Victorian era,
they had fucking,
they were putting dresses over the legs of tables because they were freaked out
that people were going to be sexually aroused by table legs.
No,
I didn't know that.
Oh yeah.
That's awesome.
He's to do with piano legs.
I mean,
they were fucking crazy.
They thought people were going to get sexually aroused by the legs of chairs.
But I mean,
on the other hand,
have you seen piano legs pretty hot?
Yeah.
It depends if you're alone and during the Victorian era,
everybody smelled pianola legs.
Probably a healthy alternative.
But I think
stay with Muslims down.
I mean,
sure.
You're like,
oh my God,
if you see someone's ankle,
well obviously you're gonna want to fuck that ankle.
I'm not sure how I it is,
but if you cover everybody up,
you know,
is that crazy that we live in a world,
it's 2014 we're talking about technology and how it's going to change the world
and,
and full transparency.
And we've got a significant percentage of the world walking around with curtains
on their head.
[inaudible] fascinating.
And not only that,
doing it on television,
like you watch them on television,
he could see it through,
transmitted through this incredible medium,
this technology,
the internet and video is displaying these people that are wearing these crazy
medieval outfits or pre medieval.
It's,
it's,
it's hard to imagine that in 2014 we live in a world where you have Google
search and women aren't allowed to drive and they're not supposed to learn.
There's a significant population that thinks that women shouldn't read,
that they shouldn't be allowed to go to school.
Cool.
Well look,
anything that wants to hold onto the past is going to fight education.
Tooth and nail is going to fight knowledge,
tooth and nail.
That's why the very first chapter of the Bible is don't eat from the tree of
knowledge.
That is the biggest sin you could ever.
Uh,
in fact,
we got expelled from heaven because we ate from the tree of knowledge.
That's what Adam and eve did.
So if you've got your old way of doing things and it ain't right,
well the first thing you want people to make sure they don't do is find out what
is right.
Yeah.
Right.
So they block your attempt to get knowledge,
but,
but to your point,
Joe there,
fuck yeah.
I mean knowledge is flooding in like a tsunami and they can't stop.
You can't stop it.
There's no way to stop it.
And I think ultimately that knowledge will,
will transcend just simply being able to Google things and read things.
And it'll be some sort of,
and,
and scientists have speculated about this,
not just a knucklehead like me,
but the scientists have speculated that what we're going to be deal with in the
probably near future,
within the next hundred years is instant access to information directly through
some sort of a neural interface.
And I believe that the exchange of tapping into something like that is that I'm
going to be able to get into genx mind too.
You're going to be able to get into mind,
but I'm going to be able to get into yours.
We're all going to be able to get into each other's minds and then that's going
to progress to that.
Ultimately that'll progress to some new level.
And I think that in a sense,
I mean there's a lot of people that they look at the Utopian version of a,
a modern technologically advanced society like becoming,
you know,
this uh,
the singularity is near type thing where we're going to reach some sort of a,
a beautiful place because of technology.
I think if any way that that is the way the,
the,
the way is not going to be necessarily through artificial intelligence but
through artificial interface of intelligence where we create something that
allows us to instantly access each other and we truly dive into this like
joining like,
like a fucking world of Warcraft server,
but the world of Warcraft server,
instead of running around playing a game,
we're going to be thinking in each other's minds.
Well,
if that day comes the first time that you go into other people's heads,
there is going to be initial period of time,
five minutes,
five days,
five weeks,
whatever it is,
where you will run into darkness before you see the light.
Okay,
sure.
Like you're going to be like,
oh my God,
that dude is thinking of the most fucked up things I,
no,
no.
He went there.
Holy Shit.
Right?
And then you're going to move on to the next mind and you're going to think the
same thing and the neck,
spine,
and you're going to be amazed at the darkness of humanity,
right?
But then eventually you realize,
oh,
we all think that.
But then we also think all these wonderful things,
and then it does like you don't necessarily mean bad by it,
right?
And then you'll get to the light of knowledge that knowing that we're all the
same.
So that guy,
that the first guy who's thoughts you read,
who you thought was the most fucked up guy on earth,
it turns out we're all just as fucked up.
Well or
it will just be the first steps to the next level that gets
like the next
generation of human beings that grows up with that technology.
Like I look at my kids now and I look at the Internet and I'm like,
wow,
what a weird world it is that these little children,
they're growing up with no access or no knowledge of what it was like to exist
in a world where there was no internet.
Well,
I think that the people that first experience this mind meld technology,
we were all read each other's minds to them and be this crazy alien concept,
but they're going to have to somehow or another reconcile it with the biological
existence that we were born into and grew up with.
And then all of a sudden,
boom,
connected to each other.
But the people that those people give birth to,
they will grow up in a world where everyone reads everyone's mind from the jump.
And that's when things would get really fucking weird.
And that's when I think the money thing will become the bottleneck.
So,
uh,
Joe,
you and I are at this point so old that
before it happens.
Well,
sure.
They'll come up with some new shit that gets you to,
I mean they've,
they've already figured out a way to use a young blood to rejuvenate mice like
essentially of MVC that,
that article,
oh my God,
it's essentially a,
a vampire strategy.
They're injecting young blood into mice and they're finding that it reverses the
aging process.
Yeah.
So it looks all that's going to happen.
Like I love when America debates,
like is this ethical and moral to do x,
Y or z?
Like whatever you're debating China's already in the middle of day.
Yeah.
Right.
Like they don't give a shit.
You know who the story Yao Ming,
yes.
The Chinese government took the tallest,
uh,
male basketball player and female basketball player and had them get married and
that's,
yeah.
Ming's parents.
Yeah.
So like you think the Chinese aren't going to do it.
They created a guy.
Right.
So there are certain DNA you're going to have to give you super strength.
There's like a German baby born a couple of years ago.
That's like huge muscular kid
myostatin inhibitors,
what regulate the growth of muscles.
And he's born without them.
So he does not have an,
an inhibition to keep his muscles grown within a certain certain size.
They existed whippets which is a dog and exists as a,
a genetic anomaly that just happens because of probably overbreeding and also in
cows occasionally in cows.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
we've seen it.
I've seen the cows too.
Crazy.
You think that they're not trying that in labs in China right now?
Oh yeah,
they are.
Okay.
So,
and you think they're not going to succeed?
They are.
They are going to succeed.
Yeah.
And then at some,
and then we will have the superhuman race and then we'll have us.
Yup.
Okay.
And then she gets really good.
Yeah.
They're going to fuck us going to hold this down.
I'm going to fuck us.
This,
this China thing or this,
excuse me.
This nice thing is,
is quite fascinating and a,
the way to,
there's an,
you can just Google it.
Um,
just look,
there's an article on CNN health,
young blood makes old mice more youthful,
but um,
they've essentially found out that when they take the blood of young mice,
it rejuvenates brain and muscle tissue in older mice,
which is a fucking vampire strategy.
I mean it's,
it's really crazy,
but that is what we're going,
we're going,
this is step one and step one is ultimately going to lead to,
you know,
step 1000 which is going to be in mortality.
So what I was saying is that we're old enough that we remember a time when there
was no internet.
When I tried to explain that the younger people,
they just,
they have a hard time grasping what that means.
That we had to actually go to a library,
try to look up a book that had knowledge on that topic,
read the book.
They,
that seems like the Victorian legs that people wanted to have sex with to them.
I mean,
that seems like it's,
you know,
2000 years before Jesus,
like that's crazy to them.
That was in our lifetime.
And so we're naturally inclined to believe that change isn't going to happen,
that things are going to always be the way they are today.
Right?
That's natural human instinct,
but that is indisputably not true.
So we've got a lot more change ahead of us and it's,
it might change things in ways that are so revolutionary.
It's hard to comprehend.
I think it is hard to come by
for hand.
I think we are the caterpillar that gives birth to the butterfly.
We just don't realize it.
We're,
we're going to become something that we don't,
we don't even see coming we have right now.
So you're super optimistic.
You think we're going to get to be butterflies?
Well,
I'm optimistic,
period.
I'm a pretty optimistic person.
I see negativity and I see positivity and I feel like you could dwell on the
negativity,
but
you could also dwell on the positivity.
You,
I'm aware of all the negativity.
I'm aware of all the terrible behavior that human beings exhibited.
I'm aware of crime where violence,
but I'm also aware of beauty and I'm also aware of information being passed in a
way that's never been possible before.
And because of that,
I talked to kids today,
I'll talk to 20 year old kids today and they're smart as fuck.
And I remember how stupid I was when I was 20 and I was like,
this kid's weight.
I tell that to my 17 year old all the time.
Like you are so much smarter than I was when I was your age.
You you have access to so much more information.
Your,
the,
the conversations that you're having are so much different than the
conversations I was having.
This is a different world.
We're living it and just enjoy it.
Take,
just take action,
you know,
in,
in exploring your own interests and,
and following your passions and soak up as much as this information as you
possibly can.
Enjoy it.
Take it all in.
Don't look at it as a chore.
Like it's a,
it's a curiosity.
It's amazing.
So I don't know how anybody could look at it in a negative way.
I see all the negatives,
I see the pollution,
I see the destruction of the environment.
I see all this,
the,
the potential global catastrophes left and right.
Both environmental and natural.
I see all that shit.
But I also see this crazy fucking monkey that knows how to fix things and,
and knows how to make videos fly through space,
you know?
And I think that crazy monkey is going to come up with some new shit and going
to continue to,
okay.
I 100% agree with you.
Uh,
and it's funny because if you watch our show,
the news is so bad so often that it's hard not to be pessimistic and I think
things are actually going to get worse before they get better.
Right?
So we're going to have the economic meltdown,
we're going to be a dark,
dark caterpillar for a while before we turn into a butterfly.
But longterm,
I'm super optimistic.
So like if you,
one of the things that I loved,
uh,
I think it was BBC put together this time chart where they showed life
expectancy over the last 200 years and you just see it go take off,
right?
Like we're also the species that went from being,
you know,
living to the average age of 30 or whatever it was to now 70 something,
from tea or,
I don't remember the exact numbers,
but it's amazing.
And we only did it in 200 years.
Life got so much better.
Like sometimes they'll last question,
a time travel,
would you go forward?
Would you go backward?
I'm like,
you're nuts.
If you go backwards,
are you crazy?
Like you think,
oh my God,
Oh,
Jane Austin time.
No,
no,
no.
You're going to go,
they're just going to ignore her conditioning.
Okay.
You're fuck you can't based,
yeah.
You want to go,
you want to go to in London?
Yeah.
We'll take a couple of months out of your life.
Right?
And you're lucky if you don't die on the way.
No,
don't travel backwards.
Set.
Terrible idea.
So things have gotten much,
much better as we have also deteriorated things.
And so I think there'll be a collision that is bad,
but then we'll get into the light and I,
I'm,
because we're ingenious little fuckers and we're going to figure it out.
I agree,
but we might not be us anymore.
And that's the real problem.
The real problem is clinging to this biological idea of what a person is.
I was looking at a who was being interviewed and he had been attacked by a shark
and he had a carbon fiber arm and a carbon fiber leg and his,
he could articulate his fingers and his,
he was standing there with no crutches,
no anything with this.
He was wearing shorts on and so from his knee down was this artificial leg and
it worked on an artificial hinge and he could walk around with no limp.
I mean it was amazing.
It was perfectly measured to the size of his body.
And I'm looking at this guy and this guy's happy to have this artificial hand,
this artificial leg.
And I'm like,
okay,
what if it's two legs and two hands?
What if it's a whole body?
What if you're paralyzed,
but they say,
okay,
you are paralyzed,
but we can take your brain and we can put it in this artificial body and you can
move around.
You're like,
fuck yeah,
give me an artificial body.
Well,
you know,
you won't be able to have sex anymore,
but,
but yeah,
I understand,
but I'll still be able to joy almost everything else that other people do.
Yes,
you will.
Boom,
you're in an artificial body.
Well,
they say,
well look,
we've got a problem.
Your brain is developing Alzheimer's,
but here's the good news.
We can take your brain and we can download all the contents of it into this
artificial brain and you can essentially live forever in this artificial body.
Whoa.
Now what?
With what the fuck are you?
Then when you become a program that's inside something that a human being
created,
then Johnny Depp just make that move that I didn't see it.
It looked like a piece of shit,
but two,
two robots that are already on their way to doing your vision to some degree.
Right?
I saw,
they were just demonstrating to chuck Hagle like two weeks ago.
Uh,
some,
uh,
Defense Department,
they,
the,
the apartment within the Pentagon that creates everything like the microwave,
all that side of the Internet.
So that department,
they've created the robots.
Uh,
and now you can control the robots from a distance.
Okay.
This is what was the controller does this,
the robot does this.
Right?
And so they already exist.
It's just a matter of perfecting them.
Right.
And then whatever's in your head,
the robot does,
that's both incredibly scary and incredibly promising.
Right.
And then there's the robots that are the sex robots right now.
They kind of suck.
Right.
But eventually they'll be awesome.
Yeah.
Then you can create any sex robot you like to have them look like anyone you
like.
Okay.
And that's a whole different world.
Right?
And so that stuff gets dark before it gets better.
Right.
Because when your wife catches you with her sisters,
robot is going to be trouble.
Yeah.
If you have a robot of your wife's sister that you keep in a box somewhere and
your wife's like my fucking sister,
you made a robot out of my sister.
Yeah,
so that's going to happen to,
that connects back to our initial conversation about nature and animals,
right?
We're trying to preserve something.
They cannot be preserved because nature is bigger than that you get,
it's more uncontrollable than that.
Right?
But that's also true of us.
So we are going to evolve into something that is different than what we have now
and that's going to trip us out because we don't like change.
We won't even exist anymore.
It's not just that we will evolve into something that we don't like.
It's we won't even be an option.
And I,
I really truly believe that that scenario that I took,
that I depicted about the guy with one arm and one leg that's happy to have that
artificial arm and artificial leg that's going to happen with the body.
It's going to happen with the whole body.
They're going to have a,
they already developed an artificial skin in a test tube that they combined with
spider web,
spider silk that is bulletproof.
They've used artificial skin cells or skin cells that they have somehow or
another to sue some scientific process that a moron like me will never be able
to truly describe,
but they've been able to,
at least in theory,
developed this bulletproof fucking skin who's not going to get bulletproof skin.
And not only that,
what,
what is skin get?
I mean you see these poor people like there's a fucking Vegas commercial that
they're airing these days with Wayne Newton.
It's a,
you know,
getting people excited about Vegas and Wayne Newton has this rubber face man,
this poor fucker,
his face is pulled back and it's shot up with Botox and fillers meets some of
these to tell him just be an older man.
It's way better than what you're doing,
what you're doing.
Yeah,
you're terrifying to look at,
but we're going to be able to just replace your fucking skin.
Forget about all that,
stretching this and pulling that and injecting into that.
How about we just take all that stupid shit off and just like we can give you an
artificial hand,
we'll give you a whole fucking,
a whole Oregon,
a whole skin Oregon that can't get cancer and it's fucking bulletproof.
Okay?
So people think,
oh,
well that's unethical.
We're not going to do that.
What does that mean?
Right?
Except when,
again,
I keep going back to China.
No,
nothing against the,
it's just they have an unscrupulous government at this point,
right?
And my wife's Chinese,
my kids are Chinese.
Okay.
So there you go.
So,
uh,
when the Chinese start making super babies,
would that are super strong like we talked about and they have a spider skin
that's bulletproof and then they start messing with the mind and the kid's
smarter than average kid.
Now what are you going to do?
You're going to have your kids be dumber than those kids.
You're gonna make the decision.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want the super babies now.
Or then the super babies will be 1% then there'll be 10% and then there'll be
30% and when they're 70% you're still going to be in that percentage saying,
oh,
no,
no.
It's okay.
I'm happy that the other kids are smarter,
stronger,
have bulletproof skin,
but mine won't.
Maybe,
but maybe not.
I'm the much more likely scenario will be that we will be,
or I say we,
the people that choose to go the route of,
of innovation and to accept what technology is capable of,
the ways that it's capable of advancing the mind will treat everyone else the
way we treat chimps,
though they're not gonna let them dominate the earth.
They're going to confine them to zoos.
They're gonna keep them locked up in certain places where they don't interfere
with the,
the,
the new evolved race and species of people.
Yeah.
I think one of the scientists said that they're worried about if aliens find our
planet,
because it's incredibly,
I think that's right,
Steve Hawks,
right.
Uh,
incredibly likely that there are,
there's other life on other planets.
Statistically speaking,
it would be crazy if there wasn't.
And if they get here,
I mean they could easily view us as we view the ants.
I mean,
how much regard do we have for the,
for the wellbeing events?
We think,
well,
they're not that conscious who gives a shit.
Right.
And we're not that conscious.
We're not that,
you know,
evolved.
And so the future us might feel the same way about us.
Yeah,
unquestionably.
I mean,
look at what we allow ourselves to do.
Two intelligent species like dolphins.
I mean,
we don't give a fuck.
We know the dolphins are smart,
but we don't know what they're saying.
So because we don't know what they're saying,
we're like,
um,
here's the fish.
Do you want to flip?
If you flip,
I'll give you the fit.
You want to leave?
Oh No,
you can't leave.
You're in the tank.
This is where you live and we're,
we're happy.
You know,
taking our kids to seaworld and watch these fucking things jumped through hoops.
No,
we're,
we're both great.
A species,
you know,
have this,
like you said,
we figured all this stuff out.
We figured out how to live longer.
We forget.
We're also vicious.
We're vicious species and don't give a damn about anybody else or anything else.
So,
um,
what happens when you amp that up?
Yeah,
well,
we're realizing that we're vicious.
We're aware that we're vicious,
but we've spent millions and millions of years developing in a world filled with
lions and tigers and bears.
Oh my,
I mean,
that's the world that we live in.
That's the reality of the world.
And that's what our DNA has developed in.
And then all of a sudden we reached this point,
whether it's a hundred years,
at 300 years ago,
whatever it is,
we,
we've reached this point where started being aware of how crazy it is,
our dominance over the rest of the species on this planet.
But it's a fairly recent thing.
I mean,
we talked about on the podcast many times,
I have this thing about wolves kind of obsessed with wolves and also obsessed
with this romanticized vision of wolves that most people have.
And the reason why this Little Red Riding Hood,
you know,
the reason why I was the big bad wolf wolves used to fucking eat people on a
regular basis.
And in Paris in the 14 hundreds there was a,
an instance where wolves had killed 40 people in Paris.
So the,
the people that lived in Paris had to band together to fight this pack of wolves
that hadn't invaded Paris during World War One,
the Russians and the Germans made a truce so that they could kill wolves because
they were in Russia.
And when Germany and the German troops and the Russian troops would go on
patrol,
they would get killed by wolves.
They ran into a super PAC and the super pack of wolves was like a hundred plus
wolves.
And they would find these people that were on patrol and they would kill them.
So they,
these Russian soldiers and German soldiers would come upon these bodies that
were ripped apart.
They would find like shoes and like some tattered clothes and the fucking
femurs,
it'd be snapped in half.
They'd suck the marrow out.
Like they had a real God damn problem.
So they had to make a truce to kill these fucking wolves.
They had to make a trip.
This is the world.
This is the real world that we live in.
This is that it's not a world where the wolves rescue the baby and bring it back
to the doorstep and wink at the family and then run off into the woods to be
with nature and Chirp around with butterflies and chipmunks.
No,
it's a fucking vicious,
horrible world of predators and prey.
And that's the world that we developed in.
And so we still have these cruel instincts because of that.
And we still have this,
this,
this ability to sort of block off our ideas that we apply to humans that we love
and in sort of alienate humans that we don't love,
decide that this is the enemy,
make these separations with,
with humans.
So of course we do it with animals.
Of course we deal with dolphins.
Of course,
we do it with almost everything we get a chance to
do.
So I've now even happier than I named my Superpac Wolf Pack.
That's great wolves,
a mother fuckers man,
smartest of all the predators because of the only ones of the super predators
that act as a group.
That's exactly why we called a wolf man.
Good.
Good name.
So like everybody tells us impossible to get a constitutional amendment to get
money out of politics and all that stuff.
Oh,
except that every generation of Americans has gotten an amendment except us.
Right?
So it's not impossible.
Women got the right to vote when they couldn't vote in the first place.
That was impossible.
[inaudible] right.
This is doable.
But when people ask me,
they're like,
dude packs her name,
like fluffy things,
like a better tomorrow,
tomorrow,
stuff like that.
Americans for America,
you know that whole thing.
What the fuck you named it?
Wolf Pac man.
Nobody like rich people are going to get discombobulated by that.
And I don't want to give money to something called Wolf Pack.
That sounds fucking dangerous,
right?
I'm like,
exactly.
We're not trying to get money from rich people.
We're trying to form a pack of a group that works together and that is super
aggressive and that is not gonna stop until we get this amendment.
And if you stand in our way,
we are going to chew you up and we're going to drink your femur.
So sad day for you and look and people get the message man,
the whether you like it or not,
we're coming,
we're in the woods and we're coming.
Well,
much like the Internet has given people the ability to access information and in
a way that was never possible before.
I think that the Internet is also going to give people the ability to express
influence in a way that's never been available before.
And a group of 300 million people mean when you say the 1% that they have,
you know,
more money than you know,
x amount of people put together and you know,
you can buy,
you take them the wealthy,
1% in this country and you combine their wealth.
But how many people that that's all well and good,
but they compete against each other.
And if you can get 300 million people in this country to recognize what a
fucking shell game it really truly is,
and then say,
look,
there's only one way to stop the shell game.
You've got to remove money from politics and you have to have politicians that
act for the people,
which is what did it initially,
the whole idea of a representative government was supposed to be about.
It was supposed to be about having people that represent the rest of us so that
everything remains fair,
that we're allowed to prosper without being pulled down by the weight of an
oppressive government like we were in Europe.
So whole reason why people came to America in the first place.
What's amazing is that in our efforts to reclaim democracy,
because it just doesn't exist on national level anymore.
Just one quick thing about that.
Princeton just did a research study.
Uh,
they went back to like I think 1981 and studied 1800 policy positions and they
looked at public opinion and elite opinion and lobbyists opinion.
Public opinion had no effect,
no effect on what our so-called representatives did at the national level.
It did not affect policy at all.
Elite opinion,
lobbyists,
donor opinion,
complete correlation.
What they wanted is exactly the policy that uh,
we got.
Okay.
So we lost the democracy at the national level and people are super discouraged
by that.
But what's interesting is that we have learned that it actually still exists at
the state level.
And so we'll go into Maine and in Maine,
one of the state reps,
it runs the cash register at her local grocery store.
She doesn't own the grocery store.
She's the cashier just sorta later it took her 250 bucks a winter seat.
Okay.
And so,
and they have public financing in Maine,
so she got the 250 from that public financing thing.
And you know what she does?
She gives a shit about the people in her district.
She represents them cause she sees them everyday at the cash register when
they're taking their cucumbers and their orange juice and stuff.
And so she doesn't want the kids poison in that area.
So she's just stopped to pollution.
She also doesn't want business to leave because business hires her,
right?
So she represents the people.
And when you find democracy,
it's like,
wow,
that's mind bending.
That's amazing.
She represents us.
And so it's a beautiful thing we're trying to rebuild.
Right?
And it actually existed here,
right.
And it seems like now we never had democracy here.
Oh,
the coups that we did and all the terrible things we did,
Yada Yada.
But on the domestic level,
Ralph Nader got Richard Nixon to set up the environmental protection agency.
Isn't that amazing?
Like right now,
Ralph Nader couldn't get Ralph Nader to put on his shoes.
Right?
Like he can't eat.
He's no way.
That seems like crazy.
And Richard Nixon was a bad ass mother fucker.
Right?
And he was like as right wing as it gets.
And he was like,
Oh my God,
I'm so sorry Ralph.
I'm so cal.
Do,
oh,
shall do.
EPA.
I'll do seat belts.
What do you need me to do?
That's how strong a populous movement was when we weren't swamped with money in
politics.
And we can get back to that.
We didn't have a major banking collapse for 50 years.
Isn't that amazing?
For 50 years,
didn't have a major bank close.
Why?
Because we actually had a democracy.
It all changed in 1976 and 1978 it was before Reagan and 76 supreme court said
in Buckley,
Valeo,
money is speech.
In 1978 in Bellatti,
they said,
corporations are human beings and hence have first amendment right to spend
money in politics.
Downhill from that moment on,
it was over.
And I talked to Nader and I said,
look,
Raiders Nader's or run a rough shot through the country,
right?
You're the original wolf pack and you're bending Nixon to your will and then you
run into a brick wall.
He said,
well,
I said,
what happened?
He said,
it was 1978.
Funny enough,
same year,
right?
And Tony Coy,
Aao,
uh,
is what happened.
I said,
who the fuck's Tony Coy?
I didn't know him at the time.
He said,
he's a democratic,
uh,
representative.
He's in the house who went to the Democratic Party and said,
oh,
because of these new Supreme Court decisions,
we can take corporate money too.
So fuck it.
We can't compete with the Republicans because they're just taking corporate
money.
Let's take corporate money too.
He said from then on,
we never had any progress.
Wow.
It's incredible that that doesn't get recognized.
Like the supreme courts recent decision,
the explain that decision for folks who don't understand what happened and how
devastating it is.
So there's two recent decision citizens United and MCCUTCHEON,
right?
So citizens United is universally recognized as the thing that,
you know,
killed our democracy,
but it isn't.
It actually shot a dead horse.
It took this system that was already super fucked and just put it up on
steroids.
So once corporations could spend money in politics,
we were fucked.
And that's when the Princeton study starts as in 1981 and from then on,
even back then,
we had no effect when in fact we,
in the previous 50 years,
we were correlated.
Our positions did matter.
Our government did represent us,
right?
So,
and then citizens United,
they just lifted all caps and they said,
oh,
if it's an independent expenditure,
like Joe Rogan is running for Congress,
I'm not given to Joe Rogan.
I'm giving to the Joe Rogan pack.
Okay.
Or Friends of Joe Rogan pack and the naked spent a gazillion dollars supporting
you guy just in,
I think it's in Montana,
set up a PAC raise all this money left the pack,
started running for Congress and that pack then just gave them all the month.
I mean,
it's a joke,
it's a fucking joke,
right?
It's just a way of giving you the money through one thin layer of legal
loophole.
And then in McCutchen they said,
yeah,
you know,
at least then you couldn't give unlimited money to the parties and there were
still some rules.
I fucked those rules.
Okay.
Now the old limit was $123,000 that you could give in any one cycle,
right?
Not through the,
the super pacs,
but to individual campaigns.
They're like 123,000 is too little.
So now you can give unlimited money to the political parties.
And so there's no limits.
You can do an independent expenditure.
You can do a super pack,
you can give to the,
uh,
politicians.
This tiny little things left,
but they're just a joke.
There are veneer left there to pretend that there are limits when in fact it's
limitless auction.
We don't have a democracy anymore.
We have an open auction for our politicians.
It's so credible that they're not accountable for that decision because that
seems like such a fucking crazy thing to decide.
It seems like such a damaging,
devastating blow to what this country was supposed to be in the first place.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing.
I wonder how they justify that.
Look,
nobody ever wakes up in the morning.
I interviewed Larry King recently.
I went on his show him before that he came on my show and I,
he says something,
I totally agree with it.
Nobody ever wakes up in the morning,
thinks that they're evil.
They think they're like the greatest person ever.
Like,
like he said,
you know,
Hitler got up and he combed his hair and was thinking like,
you're looking good,
doing good.
Right?
And so these guys have convinced themselves through a series of reading papers
from American Enterprise Institute and Heritage Foundation.
These think tanks,
venerable think tanks that they're doing the right thing.
Justice Roberts and Justice Kennedy say that giving unlimited money like this
doesn't even lead to the appearance of corruption on what fucking planet.
I mean literally there was a recent poll,
96% of Americans thinks that there's too much money,
has too much influence in politics there in the supreme courts in the 4% who
thinks,
nope,
no,
I don't see it so credible.
It's incredible.
It's like,
wow,
that's just an amazing thing to say that they don't think that it creates
corruption.
It's a,
it's a really an amazing thing to say.
What do you think is going on behind the scenes?
I mean,
do they,
does someone sit down the way,
the MSNBC exact sit down with you?
I mean,
is that really the same kind of a conversation?
No,
look,
I think obviously the,
those conversations happened from time to time,
but usually it doesn't have to get to that conversation.
I think that the system creates the things that it wants.
So for in 1971 guy named Lewis Powell writes a memo to the Chamber of Commerce
and it says,
Hey,
corporations should basically go in and affect every part of our society.
We should spend a lot of money effecting education,
affecting politics,
and effecting the supreme court.
Okay.
And Richard Nixon reads that,
and as he's getting his ass handed to them by Ralph Nader says,
maybe there's a good longterm way of fighting back.
It takes Lewis Powell,
who wrote that memo on behalf of the Chamber of Commerce and puts them on the
Supreme Court.
And then Powell is the one who has the deciding vote in Buckley,
Viva la on Bellatti that then spins us off into this nightmare that we're in
now.
So it was simply Nixon getting money from businessmen.
Businessmen wanted Lewis Powell who figured out how to,
for businessmen to take over the country.
They wanted him on the supreme court.
Nixon does them that favor because that's where he gets his money.
It's just a self perpetuating system where like Barack Obama,
he thinks he's like a lovely guy,
right?
He thinks he brought us change and he's,
you know,
oh I got you.
5% change.
You still busting my ass over this.
What the fuck?
Right?
But in reality,
what he doesn't know is that he loves the system.
He,
this system made him president of the United States of America,
the most powerful man on earth.
He,
if he was a wrestler,
his nickname would be the establishment,
right?
So Obama does what is natural to them.
What is,
how has he gotten successful this whole time?
Take corporate donations,
take donations from Goldman Sachs and give a veneer of change.
So people are placated and they keep the system going exactly as it is.
He thinks that's the right thing to do.
You know?
So Justice Roberts worked for corporations for before he was a judge,
had set up all these people that grew up in an atmosphere and in a context,
just like we were talking about with rich people,
it's the context you grew up in.
They always had money.
They didn't know.
These guys always grew up in a,
in a world where corporations were always right,
and if you argued with that,
you're a villager,
you are a barbarian,
you are a simpleton.
You didn't understand.
You need corporations to run the world and you need,
if you're a sophisticated person,
you would bow down to the Fed and a,
and a multinational corporations,
you're very unsophisticated if you don't realize that corporations are human
beings and should be able to spend unlimited money in politics.
I mean,
look at that.
That's the other thing,
right?
They all think the corporations are human beings.
I mean,
there's only three words that,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
The idea that you do that and not,
not address the diffusion of responsibility that comes with large groups act as
a large group.
The people inside that large group go,
well,
you know,
I'm just a part of this company now that is businesses,
businesses and a well I,
when we're moving to Mexico,
you know,
and if you look,
there's a woman and that was part of a insurance company in California.
She was a high level executive.
They raised the rates.
So when you're 39% on individual insurance,
and she said,
that's inhumane,
you can't do that.
People will lose their insurance and they'll die.
Right?
This was before Obamacare and they said,
oh,
that's really interesting opinion.
You're fired.
Okay,
so the machine will replace anyone with a conscience.
She had a conscious and she was immediately replaced with someone who does not
have a conscience because if they had a conscious they'd be replaced.
So we liked the media that people who are at the top levels of the media today
on the old media,
television,
et Cetera,
they didn't get there by being the smartest,
the most successful,
the best investigative reporters.
No,
no.
They got there because they were the ones who are willing to play ball.
The system rewards people willing to perpetuate the system.
Okay.
Now,
like we talked about a couple of hours ago,
that is now running into the wolf pack of the Internet,
right?
So there's a wolf pack literally that we've formed for politics,
but like the Internet is a pack in and of itself and their hate that shit.
And they're tired of that shit.
So when those two forces collide,
well,
they're colliding right now.
They are colliding right now.
And the Internet also realizes that this is the first time maybe ever that
people truly have had a voice in the ability to influence things like this.
It really didn't exist before.
You can't really,
you know,
you couldn't get on reddit and just start a thread and that thread becomes a
fucking revolution.
It didn't,
there was no access before there.
Nothing you need to,
he could start a protest,
you could meet in Washington DC and they would fucking turn the hydrants on you
and,
and sick dogs on you and shut that shit down.
And then the news would give a,
a really distorted account of what actually happened.
And for most Americans,
that would be their version of the truth.
They would,
you know,
Kent State,
perfect example,
you know,
they shot a bunch of kids and that were protesting.
The National Guard comes in,
shoots these fucking kids and what,
what it that,
I mean there was outrage because people got shot.
But w what was the,
the,
the official story that got broadcast on the news?
I mean,
what was the story that most American,
it took years before people deciphered it and saw what was really going on.
I mean,
that has been the,
the media has had the ability to do that forever.
I mean,
that's how they pulled off the Gulf of Tonkin when they got on TV and said that,
you know,
the North Vietnamese,
I've shot American submarines and sunk them off the Gulf of Tonkin.
Holy Shit.
Where or the v meanwhile didn't even happen.
They just broadcast something on television.
That didn't even happen that it's very difficult to do that today.
Very,
very difficult to do that
today.
So from time to time,
people in the mainstream media will criticize like Rto,
they're run by the Russian government or Al Jazeera.
They're run by the government of Qatar.
So that,
that,
that has validity,
right?
Flip side is what CNN run by.
So thinking about this,
when's the last time you heard CNN say the Pentagon is lying?
Never.
Right.
So the pen,
does anyone in America actually believe that the Pentagon has never told a lie?
Really?
Just anyone.
Could anyone possibly believe that?
So if the CNN never reports the truth,
it just reports whatever the Pentagon is saying,
then how are they better than providence?
Let alone our tea or I'll just zero right there.
But in fact they're more devious in a sense because they have the veneer of
being a real media organization and journalists,
etc. But when you look past that,
vineer did do a better job than providence.
It's supporting the government.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's creepy.
Okay.
And think about this.
What,
what,
what's the last investigative reports CNM broke about the gun?
They don't even have MSK to reporters.
Is that amazing?
Largest cable news channel.
They're not anymore.
But they used to be right.
The most trusted name in news.
They don't actually want to know the news.
If you had an investigative reporters,
if I was running CNN,
I'd have an army of investigator.
I've had a wolf pack of investigative reporters.
Right.
And I'd be a watchdog and I'd,
why don't they do that?
Cause they want to know they're going to get themselves in trouble if they find
out what the government's doing wrong.
That's why they don't have any investigative reporters.
Have you ever talked to Amber Lyon?
No.
Uh,
used to work for CNN.
She did this a detailed piece on Bahrain and then they turned it into
essentially an infomercial to get tourists to go to Bahrain mean she was,
I just heard about that.
Yeah.
Spring snipers shooting protestors.
And the whole thing was just a fucked system where you know,
you had an oligarchy,
you had this,
this guy who is in control of this country and just,
it was,
it was a very repressive government and very repressive scenario,
but it was also near Iran and we wanted to use their ports and we wanted it to
be able to control their ports.
So they had this relationship with the United States government.
So they essentially bought time on CNN.
Did they squashed her piece,
bought time on CNN and made like a tourist piece about Bahrain.
Look our beloved allies in the Gulf,
like Saudi Arabia.
What are they?
They're the worst governments in the world.
Yeah.
I mean,
they're the most oppressive for 50% of their population,
let alone everything else.
50% are women drive.
Can't drive,
need permission to go outside from a male.
How fucked up is that?
Right.
And,
and by the way,
15 out of the 19 hijackers on nine 11 were Saudis.
They weren't Afghans.
They weren't Iraqis.
They were Saudis,
right?
Yeah.
And we never touched him.
Saudis are lovely.
The Saudis are great at if,
because as long as you're on the side of the Pentagon,
everybody just salutes.
It's a weird world we live in,
man.
One of the,
the influence of money in politics is a,
it's so,
it's so deep and so intertwined that there's parts of it that people ignore.
And one of the ones that I bring up all the time is cigarettes.
That you've never heard a politician ever say.
We have to make cigarettes illegal.
We have to stop cigarettes.
Cigarettes are killing almost a half a million Americans prematurely every year.
They die in horrible,
painful,
agonizing deaths.
We need to stop this.
This is a plague.
If there was a terrorist that came to our country and killed a half a million
people a year,
it would be our number one priority to eliminate that terrorist.
But meanwhile,
we have this public health problem.
You don't hear that ever.
You don't hear a peep out of these people with full knowledge.
Everyone has full knowledge of this,
but it's because the cigarette companies,
the tobacco companies have given them untold billions of dollars of influence.
So because of that,
everybody shuts the fuck up when it comes to cigarettes.
That's my
nickname for John Bayner used to be tobacco checks.
John Tobacco,
Czech Spain.
Because early on in his career he got an a tiny bit of trouble.
Not that it mattered at all because he eventually now runs the house.
Right.
Uh,
because he was literally handing out checks from the tobacco lobby on the floor
of the house as they were about to vote on a tobacco bill.
Wow.
Checks.
How much would the checks scores?
I don't remember that part,
but I would like to know the number yet.
Oh,
fuck you.
It's like a million.
But isn't that like the picture of corruption?
Yes,
it is.
The picture of corruption that is it.
And look at and look at what the system did.
It took that picture of corruption.
The guy who was doing that,
John Tobacco checks Bainer and it put them to that
top of the heap.
It didn't punish him at it,
rewarded him for that.
Even the way he looks,
he looks like a character in a Batman movie that's about to make a terrible
decision.
You know,
it's got to allow some evil,
superior.
Look at that guy,
that fucking picture of him.
It just looks like a guy who's just about to fuck over everybody just when he's
got that look about them.
But you know,
if you become that guy and you exist in that world for that long,
you take on that look and you can just almost look through his eyes,
the window to the soul and see like this motherfucker needs,
oh Jesus.
What's he doing in there?
And there's a lot of those guys,
a lot of those fucking guys,
lots of them.
It's amazing.
It's amazing how intertwined the system is.
And I wonder what it's going to take to untangle it.
I wonder if we're going to be able to see that in our lifetime.
Well,
I'm trying.
I know you are.
I know you are and I respect that very much and I support that very much.
I think it's an amazing thing and I think that even,
you know,
without the your wolf pack,
I think you're trying just by distributed information and by letting people know
the,
the actual roots of it and you just get sort of getting to a points that are
being ignored by these influenced networks.
You know,
because the fact that you're not influenced by anything other than your own
opinions and the facts that at that present themselves to you.
That's super important,
man.
It's probably one of the most important things.
And I think when,
when history is,
you know,
written down in the future and we go over this era,
this will be the era of the Internet.
I really do believe that.
I believe that these decades,
this,
you know,
30,
40 years from the point of,
you know,
the first initial introduction like the early nineties when it really became a
part of America to a where it eventually is going to go to.
I think this is going to be an incredible era of,
of,
of change and have influence in a way that I don't think it's ever existed
before.
We're a part of it.
We're in the middle of it right now.
So I don't think we recognize it as my,
I think we do kind of,
we talk about it cause we were,
you know,
we literally are in it.
I mean we are one of the,
the people that's taking full advantage of this strange new time.
But I think,
well history looks back on it,
man.
They're going to look back at it like this is a crazy fucking time.
And then they invented the Internet and the whole class goes,
ah,
I know.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
to bring it back to our conversation about darkness and light.
And so the Pentagon,
that is this force of darkness for so many things,
unfortunately in the world invented the Internet.
Right?
They fucked up.
So the overall
story is a little bit more complicated than that,
but they had a huge role in it.
And so how's that for irony?
It's hilarious.
I don't think anybody could have ever possibly saw this coming.
I mean,
yeah,
I think if they could pull it back,
they probably would.
You know,
that is the number one biggest problem to govern is,
is the,
the ability that people have today to express themselves and exchange
information and the access to that information being almost completely permeated
into our society.
I mean,
it's almost complete.
It's almost everywhere.
I mean,
you basically get the news on your fucking microwave now.
it's just,
it's too much,
too much information now.
She can't hold it back.
So that's the thing,
you know,
what does the government always tried to do?
Because it most important thing is information and knowledge.
So they try to collect all the information on you.
That's why they do wiretapping of 300 million Americans.
Right?
Because they want all the info on you.
But like today,
a story we're going to do on the young Turks,
a woman getting arrested,
uh,
winds up a audio recording,
they'll arrest the cops.
Say That,
well you did not get our permission.
You wire tapped us.
So they put an extra charge on her.
Okay,
we're allowed to wiretap the fuck out of you.
Right.
But if you dare record us arresting you,
you're broken a wire tapping laws credible.
Yup.
That's because the government knows how powerful information is.
That's why they think we must have access to that tool.
And you can't have access to that tool.
Right.
But they fucked up.
Now the Internet's out there and,
and that's why they do net neutrality cause they want to kill net neutrality so
they can try to put the genie back in the bottle.
Did you hear about this?
Uh,
this guy who is some net administrator that cut the fccs a pipe to the internet.
Love that state date.
Yeah.
What was the website?
Shoot,
I forgot,
but he's like,
oh no,
no,
it's no big deal.
You're right.
Let's make it a transaction.
You know,
you guys like transactions,
you want Verizon to have the ability and Comcast have the ability to bring it
down for,
uh,
my speed on the Internet and then pay more in order to speed it back up.
Great.
So give me 1000 bucks and I'll speed it back up for you.
Your FCC website,
like outrageous.
What do you mean outrageous?
That's the system you want.
It's fucking brilliant.
Yeah,
it is fucking brilliant.
Yeah.
And then this net neutrality thing to try to get rid of that is,
is a very creepy precedent because to give anybody in,
in control,
anybody with power and influence the control of the distribution of information,
that's the very thing that's,
that's endangering their,
their power and control that distribution of information and that transparency
that's showing what these fuckers are up to.
I mean,
not enough people are up in arms,
in my opinion.
It seems to be a thing that's a,
it's escaped largely because it's being ignored by the mainstream media.
You're not seeing these stores,
you're not seeing these horrible stories of outrage all over CNN and Fox News.
You're not seeing them.
You're not,
you're not saying people freak out.
You want to know why.
Okay,
so number one,
internet is direct competition to old media like television.
Why would they want to support it?
Okay,
so that's one.
But more importantly,
all the dirty money in politics.
Where does it go?
He goes to buying TV ads.
So you think TV,
is it going to be against money in politics?
You think TV is going to be open to the Internet,
bring you that information so the politicians aren't hooked on the TV ads?
Hell No.
Nothing wants to eliminate the internet,
the free flow of information and keep money in politics more than television
does.
Hmm,
amazing.
It's your doom TV.
It's not gonna make it and now going to make it.
It's not gonna last.
It's gonna.
It's also you're,
you're,
you're going to be able to,
like,
you see these new shows that are being developed.
The school is over for the Internet,
like house of cards on Netflix.
And you're,
that's just the beginning.
It's the tip of the iceberg.
And I think shows like yours and,
and,
and these all these various shows that just popping up on the Internet,
they're going to replace everything you see on television except big budget.
Things like maybe game of Thrones that'll,
that'll,
those things we'll hang on first of all because they're awesome.
And two,
because it's really fucking expensive to make these gigantic,
huge,
you know,
shows where you have special effects and just incredible theatrical productions.
Those are going to be the most difficult to replace the captain America movies,
things along those lines.
But everything else.
So first of all,
if Edwards no,
never gets caught,
uh,
it's no problem.
She just,
Amanda come a trial by combat and then we can solve this whole thing.
Did you watch the last episode of Game of Thrones?
Don't say anything.
No,
I haven't.
Okay.
Last night.
Alright.
Nothing.
Well they say a word.
Okay.
All right.
Sorry,
I didn't know what you just said.
La,
la,
la La.
Okay.
Sorry.
Too much information there.
So they're trying to hold things at bay.
Right?
But it's like a Zombie movie with the things that you know,
we're going to crawl over the walls.
You can't build a wall a large enough and they're fighting a losing battle,
but they don't know it.
So of course like here,
I'll give you my example.
When I was at MSNBC,
I was getting about 700,009 700,000 people at night.
That was a very good number back then.
It's still a very good number right on our network.
We get about 2.1 million views a day,
so three times larger than our cable news show.
Ooh,
Cable News,
MSNBC,
wow.
700002.1 million now without TV.
So they can keep wishing it away,
but it isn't going away.
And every day TV gets smaller,
we get larger.
Well
use.
You're also available instantaneously on a cell phone while you're on a subway.
That's the difference.
Like do you could get you so much easier.
The audio version of your show,
the video version,
that youtube,
you can get it anywhere.
You know,
you could get it while you were on a fucking plane.
You could watch the youtube clips while you're on a plane flying over the
planet.
He can't really do that is,
no,
they don't.
They're,
they're model is so antiquated.
They acts as the on demand access is really,
it's very limited in comparison to what's available on the Internet.
And then when they tried to compete with us on the Internet,
look at CNN,
puts out a news clip,
like who cares what you think man?
Like Wolf Blitzer,
if you take away the CNN stuff and put them on the Internet,
and I said,
okay,
go get 'em wolf.
You're going to fail miserably.
We get like negative 17 views.
Yeah,
like in a fail miserably and there's no way you're going to have enough
personalities that are willing to freely express themselves.
They don't exist.
They just don't exist on TV.
No,
they don't exist.
So what are you going to do?
You're going to find Internet people that are going to just work for you and
then what are they going that you're going to mold
them?
Joe Again,
you nailed it.
That's exactly what they're trying to do.
Now they've are,
they,
we've gotten offers,
uh,
at at least three of our hosts,
two of them,
uh,
who've taken it cause so much more money to go to TV,
et Cetera.
Right?
Cause they think,
oh great,
we'll take the internet host and then we'll mold them to be TV and then we'll,
they'll be just as popular.
Right?
But that's what Msnbc did with me.
Oh,
incredibly popular guy online.
We'll just make him senatorial and establishment and,
but that's not what made me popular in the first place.
You miss the whole fucking point,
right?
And Look,
I love my host there.
We've got a great,
like set a host on the TYT network and I'm one of them.
It's not us,
it's not the host.
It's the idea.
And if it wasn't us,
it'd be somebody else,
right?
It's the idea that we're not going to serve the advertisers.
We're not going to serve the corporate parents.
We're not going to serve the politicians for access to celebrities for access.
We're going to serve the audience,
we're going to serve the audience.
And so how are they going to compete with,
they're not going to compete with that.
They're not.
Because someone can just set up a desk,
put a camera in front of that desk,
connect that camera to the Internet ready roll.
And they could do just as good.
I mean,
they can have a show.
You did it from your fucking living room 12 years ago and look at you today.
And if let's say that they somehow coopt us and we sell out,
right?
Someone else,
somebody else will replace Alex Jones.
He's waiting.
He's in Austin,
Texas.
You say you're the number one,
but I've got the statistics.
I've got the documents right here and show you a liar.
Jank you're a new world order puppet.
He seems like he's out there working for the people.
He's not working for the people he went for MSNBC.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you don't get to Msnbc unless you sell your soul to David dykes.
Reptilians
that was awesome.
I've never,
I never heard you do that.
That's,
that was amazing.
I've known that dude for a long time.
Alex Jones.
I in,
uh,
1999,
I did a,
a,
a DVD in Austin,
Texas and Alex Jones and I put on Bush masks.
I was a Bush Jr.
He was Bush senior and we,
uh,
we,
we wear these outfits and ran around the Capitol and it was called the live from
the belly of the beast.
It was right before Bush senior got elected.
And,
uh,
I've,
I've known him for even before then.
I've known that guy for a long time.
My theory is that Alex is a false flag operation.
Really?
Yeah.
Is that a real,
a real theory?
Kind of.
I'm half kidding.
Half serious.
You say that because you're trying to fuck with me.
What he's trying to do right now is co-op my mind.
I'm sitting here in Austin,
Texas.
I'm smoking cigarettes,
I'm drinking whiskey.
I'm getting fucking crazy trying to protect people from the government as black
helicopters.
They're flying over my dodge charger.
So that is as good an impersonation of anyone that anyone has ever done.
Well,
I've been around the dude,
like I said,
for a long time.
I know him very well.
So here's the false flag.
A conspiracy on Alex.
Okay,
let me hear the conspiracy.
If you were gonna do a bunch of conspiracies,
but you wanted to discredit the idea that conspiracies happen,
you would create someone like Alex Jones who would say plausible things like 25%
33% of it makes perfect sense.
And then on top of that,
you would add reptilians so that people will go,
oh,
that's just crazy talk.
Oh yeah.
A Gulf of Tonkin.
You think the government sat that up?
Oh,
you also think there's loser people.
You're one of those Alex goes guys chem trails.
You see what I'm saying?
I um,
I know him too well to believe that I,
I'm,
I'm friends with Alex.
I know him very well.
I would love to get the two of you together.
It'd be a fascinating conversation.
No,
I've gone on his show.
He's come on my show and like,
he's not what you think he is.
He's,
he's a little,
he's definitely crazy.
He's a little unhinged,
but uh,
he really,
um,
he believes what he's saying.
He really does.
He might not be right.
And he might jump to conclusions too often and he might cite statistics.
It may or may not actually exist or be factual,
but he's right a lot of the time.
And that's what's really fucking crazy.
He,
he made a video a long time ago,
um,
and it was a nine one one the road to conspiracy or the road to tyranny and it
wasn't just about nine 11 what it was about,
not just false flag operations,
but it was a lot agent provocateurs that I really wasn't aware of.
I wasn't aware that they will use hired people,
whether,
you know,
calm government agents,
call them soldiers,
whatever.
They,
they used people where they paid these people to infiltrate peaceful protests
and start chaos,
break windows,
light fires,
do all these things so that they would have the motivation or the,
uh,
the,
they,
they would have the green light to send in the troops to stop all these protests
because the protest turned violent.
So they turned the protest violence and I was like,
wow,
that is crazy.
And then the expression agent provocateur,
I'd never heard of it at the time,
but he does a job of detailing it in his video and,
and showing it,
not just step by step along the way,
videotaping these people that were wearing fucking,
there weren't ski masks.
They wear a military order boots.
I mean the military issue boots.
I mean they,
they,
he shows the photos of the bottoms of these boots.
He's like,
these people are all wearing the same boots,
ladies and gentlemen.
These boots are the same boots you will see on soldiers.
You'll see on police officers.
And he also detailed how they were all let off,
how they all,
they,
they coordinate him off in a building and instead of moving them in and
arresting them,
they had some sort of a negotiation.
They found a wound up letting them go.
So I don't know about the details of that,
but I do know that of course,
conspiracies exist in the real world.
So,
and false flag operations exist.
The Turkish government just got caught on tape with one of what wasn't.
So,
uh,
the foreign minister,
um,
was talking to some of the,
the generals or whoever it was that it was going to do this.
And uh,
he said,
we have a compound within Syria.
They do,
it's to protect,
um,
uh,
religious,
area,
uh,
within Syria.
Turkey controls for some obscure reason,
right?
He said,
why don't we attack that and pretend the Syrians did it?
And then that'll give us an opportunity to go into Syria right before the
elections.
So that will rally the whole country to our side.
It's on tape.
That's why,
that's why the Turkish government shut down youtube and Twitter for awhile
because the tapes,
of course,
you're not going to see that in Turkish television.
They're just as controlled by the Turkish government as any of these are.
Right.
So that's,
and then they couldn't control Twitter and Youtube and the prime minister
started losing it.
So he just shut down all of you to cause those tapes made it out there.
So that stuff definitely exists.
Well,
it drives me crazy about Alex and I,
if you've known him that long,
of course I trust you that he's not an actual false flag operation.
Might be,
I might be wrong,
I don't think I'm wrong,
but what drives me crazy about Alex is that then he'll start talking about how
the Rothschilds and the Rockefellers want to kill off 90% of humanity.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
Then you're going to stop.
Then you won't get it.
People like,
that's crazy.
That's not true.
You don't understand chank it's about life extension technology,
live extension technology.
What they're,
what they're planning on doing is taking babies.
They'll extract,
the fetus isn't,
they're going to put them in your corn flakes with radio ID,
cit,
RFID chips.
He'll,
he'll go into,
we w we have the documents,
we have the documents right here.
I'll show them to you after your show.
Oh yeah.
And then,
and then people shut down and they go,
oh,
okay,
well then that must all be full of shit.
So let's chem trails.
Um,
yeah,
I know.
I agree.
I agree that there's no evidence whatsoever that they want to kill off a giant
percentage of the population mean they used like the Georgia Guidestones is like
the evidence of this.
Like you know,
keep your population below 500 million on the world.
I,
I'm with you.
I don't agree with all of its conclusions,
you know,
at all.
Not even a little bit,
but I think having a loony toon dude out there like that,
pushing buttons and pulling chords.
What's interesting is some things,
sometimes things get brought to light like the Bohemian Grove,
like wait a minute.
World leaders really do dress up like fucking like,
like,
like Obi wan Kenobi and light an effigy on fire under the Molik the owl God
statue.
Like what the fuck?
Like these are world leaders and bankers and these people really do meet there
every year.
I mean he really did uncover that there's the weird skull and bones type shit he
was talking about that way before the John Kerry a Bush election.
So oftentimes the great majority of the time,
in my opinion,
there is no cigar filled room.
It's just you build a system and it rewards certain things and provides this
incentives for other things.
And that's why you have people,
news actors who do what they do.
You have Barack Obama who does what he does,
but sometimes there is a smoke filled room.
Hey,
sometimes you get a speech at Msnbc saying,
no,
you didn't get the message.
You got to act like the establishment,
right?
Yeah.
And sometimes you have these crazy guys like real important people dress up in
funny costumes,
get together and pat each other in the ass.
And
that's real.
And that's trippy man.
It trippy.
I mean look,
it's so when you go back to the masonic lodges and stuff,
that's like powerful gift people getting together and doing each other solids,
right?
Yeah.
And,
and they,
they want to feel better about it.
So they would do a club and their fraternity or whatever they are and they wear
funny hats and
Oh,
how old?
When you look at dollar bills and you see all the fucking cryptic shit on there
and the the pyramid with the eye above it.
Like what,
what,
what's going on here man?
What exactly is all this?
What are you guys up to?
Like what's going on behind the scenes?
So Dan Brown and what was the famous book?
DIVINCI code.
Yeah,
so the one thing I got out of that book was,
well he's right.
I mean the symbols did get there for a reason.
There's symbols all around us.
They did mean something at sometime to somebody.
So it's not an accident that there an eye on the pyramid.
I don't know what it means and I'm not sure that it's nefarious and I'm positive
it's not about the lizard people,
but you know,
at some point and look,
the masonic lodges were probably good things.
You know what,
my guests,
I have no idea.
But my guess is that those are the people who were smart enough to get together
and be like,
yeah,
religious bullshit.
Right?
We all agree.
Yeah,
it's totally bullshit.
Okay.
Now let's like come up with logical shed to actually run this place cause
they're villagers out there believe in nonsense.
So let's come up with logical rules.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So it might've had a good time and then,
but then once you get Pete powerful people in the room,
they're like,
we should,
we should set the rules in our favor,
right?
Yeah,
I agree.
Yup.
Yeah,
exactly.
Info wars.com ladies and gentlemen,
for more details we are,
we're at a time,
man,
we,
we ran into three hours.
That was,
it flew by.
We could do another three like that.
Easily.
You don't what it wound up being like my first show ever a half about politics
have about philosophy.
That's okay.
Yeah man.
That's kind of how we kind of all seems to fall into that.
Well that's kind of life,
right?
It isn't it.
It's about like who's running us?
Why do we think the way you think sex,
all those things.
Food.
Oh,
everything gets lumped in together.
We could have talked about sex a little bit more,
but that's okay.
Next time.
Thank you brother.
It was a lot of fun,
man.
I really appreciate it.
Oh No,
no.
This is incredible conversation.
I'm glad we finally got got this done.
We'll do it more often.
No,
no,
I'll do yours too,
for sure.
Absolutely.
Absolutely love.
This is my kind of show.
So,
uh,
how would you do it anyway?
Beautiful.
Awesome.
Glad to hear it,
man.
All right.
Uh,
follow,
uh,
Jank online.
Jank Ugur it's c e n.
K.
U.
Y.
G.
You are on Twitter,
the young Turks.
You can get it on youtube.
What does a website,
okay.
Tyt network.com.
That's our website on youtube is youtube.com/.
T.
Y.
O.
You got the fucking the Korean cat right on the front.
Oof.
Yeah,
he's got a hot ass haircut.
Yeah.
Isn't even making everybody else have that haircut too,
isn't not the rule.
It's a rumor,
but I think it's probably unsubstantiated government propaganda.
And if you,
uh,
if you want to know more about wolf pack,
it's Wolf Dash Pac pac,
wolf-pack.com,
Info wars.com.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we fight for your future.
Thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com use the code word row a row.
What's my name?
You use the Code Word Joe,
j.
O.
E.
That's squarespace.com.
Use the code word,
J,
r.
E four l j.
O e.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I mine as much after three hours of talk,
squarespace.com use the code word Joe j o e for 10% off your first purchase and
a free trial@squarespace.com and uh,
we are also brought to you by audible.com go to audible.com forward slash Joe
four a free audio book and 30 free days of audible service.
Thanks also to onnit.com that's o n N.
I t.
Use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
We will be back tomorrow night,
9:00 PM with our 500th episode with Doug Stan hope and Tom Rhodes.
Can't wait much love big kisses to all ma.
Hm.